the trial
of derek chauvin in the death of george
floyd continues
and man i gotta say after today and
after the other day
to me i think intent is off the table i
feel like if
if the jury sees what i see and they
probably don't because you know who
knows i don't think i'm always right
about everything but i look at this and
i'm just like
wow was it bad for the prosecution i'll
just give you a couple of the big points
the defense apparently got the got
floyd's vehicle searched eight months
later
found a speed ball with this dna on it
this is like the big story that's
breaking right now i mean
boom right there you've got causation
changes who actually
was responsible for the death of george
floyd was it maurice lester hall his
friend who was dealing
or was it derek chovan well i'll tell
you this the state
brought in a paid expert to testify
to say the things the state wants the
jury to hear and in cross-examination
the defense said
based on active resistance
derek chovin would have been in the
right to immediately
approach george floyd and taze him
tasers as you know can be lethal cause
cardiac arrest
the defense pointed out however chauvin
chose to use a lesser
force option of restraint and the
state's witness
agreed that george that that derek
chovin used
lesser force it's crazy because he had
previously testified that using the
restraint was excessive force and the
defense effectively got him said well
couldn't he have used more yes so it
wasn't excessive it was less
yes boom intent is off the table if
chauvin had the opportunity to use more
force decided not to do it and to use
less
i don't see how you prove he was trying
to hurt this guy so we're gonna talk
about all this we got a bunch of other
stories too
we got stuff about project veritas and
we got gun control stuff we'll get into
that joining us today is
brandon tatum what's up what's up man
glad to be here
introduce yourself what do you do who
are you oh i'm brandon tatum some of
y'all may know me i'm online i'm a
little youtuber guy
um i speak around the country i'm a
former police officer i was a police
officer in tucson for six and a half
years
um that's about it man but you're gonna
you're gonna be able to give us a
view into being a cop you're a cop for
what like six you said six years six and
a half years man i was an fto
just like chauvin um i was on the swat
team i did a lot of stuff on the police
department
um i testified in court plenty of time
so i think uh
we could talk about some good stuff on
it it's gonna be interesting considering
the questions being posed by the state
prosecutor and the defense i think
you'll have
probably a really great take on it so
we'll jump into it we got ian's yeah
it's ian crossland over here just found
out all our dads were firemen
yeah chief and a couple lieutenants that
was pretty cool
yeah yeah me in the corner pushing
buttons my father was not a fireman i
feel very left out but i'm here yeah
only the firefighters here
so ladies and gentlemen we're gonna
we're gonna we want to jump into this
news before we do make sure you go to
timcast.com
become a member to help support the show
we're gonna have a special exclusive
members only segment
after the show so if you want to watch
that go to timcast.com become a member
we've got a bunch of really awesome
segments even full on episodes we got
like a full bonus episode of michael
malus
talking about the keys to success giving
you know we give advice that was given
to us that we thought really helped us
and then we got jack murphy for some
reason there's a picture of me holding a
flintlock pistol you can learn what
that's all about becoming a member
but before we get into the big news and
get the show going make sure you like
share subscribe hit that notification
bell your comments your likes all that
stuff really does help because you know
you're basically telling youtube hey we
like this show the show is good and if
you're listening on itunes spotify or
any other podcast
then give us five stars leave a good
comment and share the show with your
friends the best thing you do to help
out the show we greatly appreciate it
but let's just get straight to the news
man no more waiting
this is where it gets crazy the daily
mail reports derek chauvin jury
hears how his defense team found half
chewed speed ball
pill in patrol car with george floyd's
dna on it
eight months after cops searches so this
is the patrol car
so we already had this i don't know if
you saw this uh early on uh brandon the
judge
said that it looked like george floyd
ingested something he put something on
his tongue
a pill or whatever now we got the all of
this stuff is is
it all right i gotta split on it's crazy
the defense has not even begun its case
yet the defense has not even brought in
its own witness and already we're
hearing
that derek chauvin could have used more
force
that even one of the witnesses agreed
with the defense that chauvin's knee was
not on the neck but in fact
on the on the shoulder between the
shoulder blades so this is all striking
at intent now the craziest thing about
all this with all the stuff going on
the media keeps telling you because we
talked about this last night the media
keeps telling you
oh the cop said chauvin bad the cop said
chauvin couldn't do this
and they get all these people in the
prosecution they get all these cops
coming up and saying like chauvin
shouldn't have done that that was
excessive force
and then the media comes out and says
see look this is it
they haven't proved that they haven't
proven that chauvin was innocent
not realizing the most important thing
the the burden of proofs on the state
the state can come out with all the cops
in the world given their opinion
but all the defense has to do is poke
one hole in one argument
and that's it so now that we got the
story drop and about a speed ball which
is fentanyl and methamphetamine mixed
together being found in the patrol car
with floyd's dna on it causation goes
out the window
now it's like okay what really caused
the death of george floyd because we had
the medical examiner's statement
but what is the jury going to believe is
there going to be reasonable doubt so
we get this tax report it shows he had
fentanyl or fentanyl methamphetamine in
the system
and then the defense seems to be doing a
pretty good job with the state
so you combine that with the state's
uh own witness saying that chauvin could
have used a taser if he wanted to but
chose to use a lesser
amount of force i think intent is out
the window
yeah i think i think it's going really
bad for the for the state
i don't think that they're doing a
really good job at proving their case
the burden of proof is on them it's not
the defense and people may think it's
the defense but it's not
and just because a police officer does
something that's stupid or maybe that
other police officers wouldn't do don't
make it criminal
none of that matters what matters is the
law what's on the books what is his what
what are his charges
and can the state prove beyond the
reasonable doubt that those charges are
affect
are in effect i don't think that they
will i think that
that uh officer chauvin did a bunch of
stuff that i wouldn't do but i don't
think that there's
any malice any depraved mind which is in
the statute
of him trying to kill george floyd
outright i i so that's murder two and
three gone
yeah murder two and three gone um in the
in the manslaughter charge
is is obviously with the intent or
with negligence or knowing that you're
doing something that could cause a death
of a person so
if he was kneeling on his neck with
the knowledge that his unreasonable
action will cause the death
of george floyd then that's where they
can get him in now they can't prove that
man
i don't think that they can prove that i
don't think they've done a good job at
proving that because you can look at the
video footage from today
where they show the angle of his knee is
facing towards the patrol
vehicle which would not be at the proper
angle to be
consistent with being across the neck of
george floyd
it's it's showing that it's up on maybe
a part of his neck and on his upper
shoulder area
which is how the maneuver is trained i
did the maneuver like that plenty of
times
never put the knee on the neck but you
do put it on the upper back people think
it's the neck
well check it out even if you're this is
what people don't understand
even if you're trained to put the knee
on the back
in a heated situation with someone
actively resisting
using their feet to kick people
surrounding you screaming and
threatening you
is it reasonable to say that someone
might poorly execute the maneuver
well and well i'll say this i don't
think this is the situation where
unless you're a trashy cop that any of
what happened should cause you to poorly
produce any maneuver i mean
george floyd was pretty much subdued um
he had two people on his back
chauvin had pretty good control over
over him on the upper part of his body
he requested to be laid on the ground i
don't think george floyd wanted to fight
he didn't want to go to jail right he
didn't want to get in the car he'll say
whatever he needs to
he was hoping that somehow he had a
medical emergency where they'll take him
to the hospital and probably not in the
back of a patrol car
that's why he was complaining and making
all these claims
therefore they wouldn't it would
necessitate them to call the ambulance
and not take him to jail
and so i think that's what that's what
george floyd was attempting to do
however i've been in situations that
were way more intense
than what chauvin was going through now
of course i wasn't on the scene so i
don't know what he was feeling i don't
know the energy that was there
i don't know the effect of the people
that the people had on him
but it wasn't that crazy i had people
who are way crazier
i had dudes who were way stronger who
were actively
lifting police officers up while they
were on his back
he's on the ground lifting them off
their feet
because he was so high on drugs now
that's a situation where
your knee may slide from the shoulders
to the neck
and now you're in a position where
you're you're probably fighting for your
life because if he
happens to get up he's going to hurt you
if you got three men can't hold him down
he's going to probably hurt you
so i'm is what i'm trying to say and i'm
not trying to say in any way to defend
chauvin i'm just presenting a logical
defense
in in terms of what you know what the
defense could be bringing up chauvin
could just be a really bad cop like he's
like bad and like he doesn't know what
he's doing
he's he's just some people are good at
basketball some people are not good at
basketball you know what i mean
so chauvin is in a situation where it's
not that intense
for manslaughter like you said it's got
to be negligence like you were doing
something that
could have reasonably caused harm and
then you killed somebody but if chovin
is trained
in brazilian jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu or
ground control techniques
and they're like here's what you do and
then he goes the like this does it wrong
how can you argue that he was even
trying to cause harm any capacity
if he was trying to use a ground control
maneuver that the cops are trained to do
and he's just not good at it how do you
get him on a crime yes
i mean you're 100 correct i mean they
cannot expect
that everyone's training and they
brought it out the defense brought this
out that everyone's training is not
100 consistent you have a little stick
figure that's on a picture
that shows a little bit about how you're
supposed to do things i did training i
train officers
some officers train things a little
differently even in the same police
department
they may be a little more aggressive and
say oh it doesn't matter if you
if the shin touches the base of the neck
some are say
you better not touch his neck same
department same training staff
tells you a different story now when
you're in the heat of the moment which
the defense brought up
you can improvise you may improvise you
may make mistakes
and the bottom line is that did the
mistake that he made caused the death of
george floyd because nobody cares if he
made a mistake
nobody cares if he's a crappy police
officer nobody cares if he did the
maneuver right or wrong it doesn't
matter
because if he died from taking a bite
out of a speed ball if he
you know died from methamphetamine
fentanyl he was actually dying from the
moment he put it in his mouth
and he was just a ticking time bomb then
none of what the prosecution is bringing
forth is going to matter
you you saw what happened with maurice
lester hall right yes
so he's he's the friend of george floyd
who was supposed to testify for the
state
political fear he pleads the fifth but
more than that his lawyer comes out and
says
yeah he could be he could incriminate
himself in third degree murder charges
in the death of george
floyd and it's like what i was surprised
the jury wasn't in there for that though
yeah okay that's why i was surprised she
said that i was like
you're making the case for why he should
probably be charged
right you're saying that he shouldn't
say anything that incriminates himself
but you are articulating
a criminal uh a a defense or at least a
incrementable i i i make that up today
incriminable i don't know i don't know
what word to use
incriminating statement incriminatable
that can
y'all could use that now
so an incriminating statement that could
raise questions i i don't understand why
why she would do that but he was
culpable in that situation
and i want people to understand that as
well and that's what the defense is
bringing out and the jury may not hear
that statement
but they can see with their own eyes
that us a lot of people that were
culpable here
i mean even the the firefighters and
even the medical staff and even the
dispatcher
all of that leading to a delay in the
firefighters getting there
possibly delaying um george floyd
getting medical treatment it's all
everybody all these people are are now
slightly culpable
so to put all of the blame on chauvin
which is what they're trying to do
is is not a really good strategy that's
going to pass it just feels like they
want a scapegoat
they made him the number one villain
because he's the guy you can see with
the neon george floyd
there were other cops there too and
there were cops that were there before
he got there
and you know when this all first went
down everybody basically watched the
video and was like dude that's messed up
like he should have done that but that's
i guess we all fall for this sometimes
because
we don't know what was going on so the
the the defense pointed out that chauvin
received a priority one call
you know sirens lights rushed to the
scene we've got an active resistance
from a guy who's six foot six 230 pounds
and so this work it's crazy because then
he asks this
okay this is this is important the state
literally paid this guy
how much did they pay him ten thousand
ten thousand ten thousand to pay him
right there and then they paid him
another like 30 some hundred
just to show up in court so to be a
consultant or expert witness ten
thousand
and then they paid them so this guy that
was the state
paid to come to tell the jury chauvin
did bad
basically says that chauvin as soon as
he got that priority one call
and heard there was active resistance
chauvin could have walked out of his car
drew his taser and
and just fired at floyd he could if he
wanted to
and that would have been reasonable in
in the expert's opinion
that's insane the temperament they the
defense was able to
establish a well-mannered temperament
which kills the deprived mind depraved
mind
articulation and i think the third
degree murder charge or whatever it
kills that articulation because
people have to understand level one
calls
are the highest priority call that you
can get
the highest that mean an active shooter
that means somebody's killing somebody
there being a man with a gun are all
level one that's the highest priority
card
that's what he got that's and and if he
got a level one call which i think came
out in court
your adrenaline because you can't see
the scene
yeah you only have a mental picture of
what you produce based on your train on
your experiences
so when you hear rookies on the radio
saying we
guys fighting and they're struggling you
can hear it on the video he's on drugs
or
whatever it cut foods it seemed like cut
foods in the hood it seemed like they
all kind of stuff happening
at cub foods but when you hear it over
the radio you can't see
george floyd you can't see a guy that's
cracked out his mind you know a myth out
of his mind
you can't see if the officers really
have control or not
you are going off for your own memory
and experience so when the
when the level one call comes out and
you hear it over the radio your stress
level goes out of the roof
because you're imagining the worse he's
probably imagining that these rookies
are getting handed to him
by this big crazy guy that's high on
these drugs
and when he get there he sees that he's
sitting in the car
he calms himself down right he's not in
out of control
deranged i want to kill a black man
today police officer that they are
presenting him as and he's five foot
nine 140 pounds
and he knew chauvin's that's right he
knew floyd they knew each other they
worked together
the same bar but i don't think it was
proven they actually knew each other
they were both the statement was that
they never entered and never had that
has not been talked about in the last
few months yeah because
i think that what people fluff that up
because they want to have a
conspiratorial angle yeah but in reality
you can work in the same facility with
somebody and not be
um not know them you know apparently
uh they've worked in different parts of
the building different ships and they're
hired by two different
i mean it's like two different hiring
processes so i'm pretty sure shoving
worked
off duty as uniform police which that
goes through the police department
i'm sure george floyd was hired through
their staff probably in a one-to-one
or maybe an agency how about this ian
what if you're right what if chauvin
gets his call
priority one call get the lights on
speed there quick we got a six foot six
230 pound guy
he's fighting with these rookies the
rookies are freaking out he can hear on
the radio he's resisting we need backup
chauvin goes oh man he starts sweating
bullets he hits the gas he pulls up and
goes
oh it's it's floyd puts his taser away
walks over and says i'll put him on the
ground
floyd said put me on the ground man put
me on the ground so what if shovel was
like oh dude i know this guy i'm not
going to tase this guy
yeah what about that that's also
possible crazy well which it didn't end
that hurts the prosecution it makes it
seem like oh no he's personable he knew
him
that's why he didn't tase him right away
that's why he didn't he didn't go
they didn't they didn't they didn't go
hard on him like
i would have i would have i would have
gone harder on him
on floyd on floyd initially not on the
ground
we wouldn't have gotten to that point
and the reason why is because you don't
want to get to that point
you don't want to get out of control you
don't want to get a person getting too
confident
and then they start doing all this crazy
stuff and now you have to use crazy
amount of force on them in the end like
they're kicking themselves
but think about this then he falls out
and bumps his head and
breaks his neck but you're going to be
liable for that and think about this
they put him in the car and floyd on the
body camera is saying put me on the
ground put me on the ground
and he's kicking and so chauvin goes all
right i'm i'm going to give him i'm
going to do what he wants
shelving should have been like nah when
i'm not putting him in the shower dude
if you were harder on him
earlier he wouldn't have had the
opportunity to like command you to put
him on the ground yeah you got to make a
decision you got to make a decision
these guys are rookies so they they
don't have a lot of experience with
these high intense situations and the
guy is big
and they don't know floyd he could start
swinging you know he could start going
crazy on them and they're they're out
there flustered
so in the beginning when he was cool
you'd be cool with him if you're gonna
try to attempt to put him in a patrol
car you need to either put him in there
or you don't put him in there
and if you put him in there you need to
start accelerating because you're gonna
have to get him in there
if you play around with him he's gonna i
can't breathe and he's gonna kick
himself out of the car on the on the
ground
and now he's on the ground and you're
not gonna get a six foot six two hundred
thirty pound
crack head uh a meth head into a patrol
car after he's prone on the ground he's
never going in a patrol car after that
so if you want to put him in there you
put him in there you use force and you
put him in there you make him get in the
car
and then you shut him in or you don't
this is crazy i mean
when you go through the body camera
footage and based on what you're saying
it sounds like they went
i i'm not trying to say well i'm just
going to say it it sounded like
they were they they didn't do enough
they they weren't
i don't want to say aggressive it's not
the right word they weren't assertive
enough they didn't put them in the car
close the door and leave
him there they opened it up they played
around with him like you said
yeah and if they just told floyd we're
not putting you on the ground
we're not going to do what you're asking
you're under arrest none of this would
happen
i believe so i mean i've been in this
situation before
plenty of times probably a hundred times
and when you let people get an inch they
take a mile
you have to experienced police officer
will be able to diagnose very quickly
that george floyd is either having a
real medical emergency or he's not he's
playing
he's he don't want to go to jail this is
what they do they claim a medical
emergency
so that they can have the police the the
ambulance come and they hope to go to
the hospital
hoping that you will because what
happens is if if you swallow drugs
right a fake a fraudulent 20 bill isn't
a serious charge
in many jurisdictions they're not going
to waste their time trying to go too far
if you end up having a medical
complication so
typically what could happen is that you
have a medical complication you claim it
you have some type of reaction to
swallowing drugs
instead of you get in the back of the
police car going to the substation you
go to the ambulance go to the hospital
they have to pump your stomach and do
all these other things many police
departments do what we call long form
which means they leave you and they
follow up with you later on
and they may not even arrest you take
you to jail they may give you a ticket
and walk away
and so a lot of people who are in the
system they know the game it
they either swallow the drugs and claim
something or they try to get themselves
out of going straight to the jail
do you guys uh where where where were
you a police officer tucson arizona
did you guys have i bond eye bonds no
that is what is that
so i think that's what it's called in
illinois where they basically arrest you
but i do air quotes because what happens
is the cop will walk up to you say
you're under arrest
fill out a form sign this oh yeah you're
free to go we call it sight and release
it's called a paper ticket or whatever
because every like you still got court
yeah it's it's basically the same as a
rest but they just don't bring you to
the station so what happens is they give
you a ticket and you sign a ticket
promising to appear in court
if you fail to appear in court now they
can get a warrant for your arrest so
it's the same process without booking
because what happens is you know in many
of the police departments people don't
notice that if the county runs the
police
the the jail the police department the
city has to pay for every person they
intake
and that's a money that could be a money
grab so what we did as a police
department people who were uh
dui um well no not dui but people who
are marijuana
in possession of marijuana because in
arizona the threshold is two pounds
and then you you know whoa then that's
then you gotta go to jail yeah
anything with you guys gotta huge bag
and you're like you're at one point nine
you're good
yeah one point nine dude yeah smoke this
all day and so it's a usable amount of
what they call a personal use
so anything under two pounds you can
cite and release people
depending on what you want to do so what
we would do is we'll sight and release
them in most cases
unless there's more you know
circumstances surrounding your arrest
like multiple arrests or whatever
we'll take you to the jail cell either
way it go you're promising to appear in
court either through booking
or you're promising an appearing court
on the side of the road and uh if you're
not a big threat of fleeing
they'll just sign your ticket and you'll
walk away you ever have people you saw
doing like a non-violent crime and
you're just like i'm not gonna
yes i'm not gonna mess with this guy yes
all the time so like what's a good
example of that if
you well like somebody's drinking
alcohol like you know i'll be going to
another call priority called or doing a
beat and i see the same drunk
because because um you know drinking
alcohol in public is a crime
same drunk out there on on public
property on private property
drinking a 40 ounce and he's just drunk
he's gonna drink that thing and go
behind the building
and nobody cares he's just he's a
neighborhood drunk or he's going to go
off to a
a house in in a squad it's waste it's a
waste of my time
because there are people who really need
my services maybe if the day is slow i
may go and address the gentleman but
other than that you know you let them go
you know sometimes you see a person
you know was that a hand-to-hand or was
it not you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah
and nowadays if you're white i guarantee
you they're looking like oh no it's not
worth it
do i want to be on the news do i want to
go to prison do i want to lose my job
if the cop is white if the cop is white
and the purpose black
because you're like if this turned into
a fight it's over hand-to-hand is where
it looks like they're handing each other
their hand to drugs you may shake hands
they could just be shaking hands
they could be shaking hands or whatever
the case may be or whatever they're
doing
or they could be selling dope but do you
want to go down that path
when you got an hour left on your shift
and this could
end up being a fight for your life dude
can pull a gun on you or whatever cops
do make those decisions i don't know how
prevalent i never had to
be put in a position to do it to make a
decision on a hand-to-hand i work the
midnight shift
nobody's out you're doing hand-to-hand
at 12 o'clock at night it's on
but i i gotta wonder if the state is is
actually throwing
the prosecution on purpose like i'm
reading this these blog posts from legal
insurrection they got great analysis
you look at abc cnbc you know and
whatever
and they're basically like the police
say chauvin did this wrong police say
shove and use excessive force
witness says shove into this and they're
only telling you
one side of the fight so it's like the
way i described it yesterday is
it's a boxing match where the
commentator is saying like you know oh
brandon hits him again hits him again
hits him again
and they don't what they're not telling
you is that for every time you hit ian
ian hit you five times
yeah so then when the when the ref's
like ian wins people are like what
people are being set up to believe that
chauvin's going to get convicted because
the mainstream headlines but anyway i
digress i'm reading these these
the the legal insurrection analysis
about the state's own witnesses
constantly backfiring on the prosecution
they bring in this mpd officer
to talk about like training use of force
and he's like
oh i once did the same thing it's like
oh geez dude and so i'm wondering
and i'm not saying it's true i'm just
saying it's a thought is it possible
that the state is like
if chauvin actually goes down for this
we're going to get 200 cops just
quitting overnight
they're not going to want to work cause
like you mentioned right if you're a
white cop and you see
you know someone doing a handoff or
whatever you're going to be like oh dude
i'm not going to be that guy in the news
being called a racist
how many cops are going to look at what
happened with chauvin and be like
am i next am i going to be told to go
and subdue some guys on drugs and
they're going to try and put me in jail
for it
yeah i think that definitely the second
part of what you said meaning that cops
are going to have an adverse action
to show them getting prosecuted
especially when the case is so weak
i don't think the prosecution is trying
to throw it i just think they don't have
a lot
this was all conjured up on bs from the
very beginning
this is only getting attention because
he's it's a white cop and a black man
and
in the video it's kind of intense like
if you just look at it with a naked eye
you're like dang
that look really bad so this is the only
reason why it's getting this much
attention other than that
this is no different than like eric
garner right i mean
eric garner was presumably choked which
it wasn't a choke i don't care what
nobody said he didn't choke the guy
he presumably choked um the gentleman
and then he subsequently died from
complications of a heart attack or
whatever whatever stuff that was going
on he was a ticking time bomb
well the knee on the upper shoulder back
was accelerating the ticking time bomb
or maybe had something to do with maybe
had something to do with the ticking
time bomb of george floyd
so if the guy and uh the
other case got off then why would
chauvin be
prosecuted for a similar reaction
so the the cop in there garner's choice
i can't think his name
yeah eric garner he got he got to quit
is that what happened yeah he got fired
but he got a question
right yeah and he's going to get
acquitted
if if it keeps going the way that it's
going i think i think what happened to
eric garner is
is tragic and ridiculous and it makes me
pissed off at the at the system in the
police department the dude was selling
lucy's
you know he's like sitting on the street
corner he's giving out single cigarettes
to people
so they try to they try to uh arrest him
for it now i get it you know
weinstein said you know he's a smart guy
in order for society to function
cops need to be able to arrest people
you know you can't resist cop walks up
to you yeah you're not going to win a
fight by getting trying to get into a
fight with a cop and refusing and
resisting
you you got to win through the system
and it's not perfect and it's not great
but then i just think it's kind of dumb
that this dude was just standing on a
street corner well let's put it in
perspective
do we really know what he was doing no
we we don't know we weren't there
he was saying i'm just doing this that's
a good point he was just that's what he
was saying
i i've never met a criminal say i have
maybe once
that says come arrest me officer i'm
doing all kind of crimes here
let me write down the crimes that i'm
committing so i go to prison for life
nobody's gonna do there's actually the
famous story of that guy who robbed a
bank
for one dollar and then after he went
and sat down waiting to get arrested
because he had cancer
oh he wanted to get health care from
prison because he couldn't otherwise
yeah
that's crazy stuff i had a guy i had a
guy we were at midnight shift man i'm
just
hanging out just finished crazy writing
crazy case reports and we're at the qt
getting ready to get some donuts this
guy
come up to us screaming arrest me take
me to jail
help arrest me and we like duke stop
what is your problem
he pulls out a bag of weed because we
said we said no we're not arresting you
he pulls out a bag of weeds like arrest
me now and we all looked at each other
like
who's gonna write this case report so
some people do it they do it
why did he do it but but eric he was
high on drugs
yeah and he was he was schizophrenic so
he was afraid people trying to kill him
so he wanted to go to jail to be safe
and he happened to have weed in his
pocket and he
presented it and that's what he needed
to go to a doctor man i know we
we took him we took him we took him to
jail for
for a few reasons i think he ended up
having a warrant he was in possession of
marijuana but he can't get help from
jail
they they will refer you to medical
services if you have that problems in
jail in in
tucson you ever see the movie watchmen i
don't think so
i love that movie it was a it was a much
better comic graphic novel
but uh uh in the movie it's basically
about a bunch of superheroes vigilantes
they wear masks
uh that's like they wear masks yeah it's
like part of the premises that
they're not necessarily all super
powered there's people who put on
costumes and fight
you know crime and uh a law passes where
you can't wear masks anymore like
mass vigilantism is a crime and so
there's a scene in the movie i think
it's in the comic as well
uh where these two heroes are
reminiscing about this one villain who
was constantly like arrest me
arrest me and they were like we'd always
ignore him and then rorschach
who's like this he's one of the
characters he's a moral absolutist and
they're like whatever happened to the
guy
and then night owl goes rorschach
dropped him
dropped him down an elevator shaft
yeah but that's what it reminds me of
the guy walking walking up to you being
like arrest me here's drugs
take me in yeah in in the case of uh
eric garner like this is this is the
thing that that that i think is a
two-fold
thing here eric garner shouldn't have
been breaking the law
he had been arrested 40 some times
before this one some of his arrests
included selling lucy some of them
included resistant arrests
but you got to think about capitalism
and freedoms
the store that's selling full price
cigarettes
is getting gypped because you got this
guy
who refused to work for the store or get
a real job is selling cigarettes for a
cheaper price right in front
right in front of his business and this
star called the cops stork i don't know
if they call the cops in this instance
but somebody called the cops because
they showed up
not unless they were surveilling him
right right which these guys looked like
they were in plain clothes but i don't
know if they
were pd i don't know if that's the way
they do pd in in
out there or not the the problem i have
is you know when i see this video of the
eric garner situation and i'm like it
pisses me off i see the george floyd
thing it pisses me off
i see a lot of these videos that
everybody gets pissed off
and in my initial reaction when these
stories started you know becoming
prominent through social media
was sympathy and support for the
activists then i started
actually looking at the evidence then
the george floyd thing was basically a
big punch in the gut for me
because when the george floyd thing
happened conservatives liberals
moderates everybody was pissed off
everybody i i think i was pretty upset
yeah yep
everybody was coming out saying nah this
is this is not good we want justice
and here's what pissed me off then the
evidence comes in then you're like oh
geez dude
we we we all jumped the gun a little bit
but here's the problem
when people who are like moderate
liberal conservative
of any persuasion actually investigate
and find out oh man we
we might have been wrong on this one
they come out and say it
when they think there's injustice they
call for justice
but these leftists when they're wrong
they just stop talking about it they
should ignore it just disappears
yeah and they have to you know for me i
always maintained that i thought that
what he did was dumb and i you know that
guy caused
a hail storm that didn't need to happen
because george floyd could have died but
he could have
he could have played to the camera you
know you're a white man on a black man
and he's saying i can't breathe he
crying for his mama even if he's wrong
even if he's lying even he's playing
you play to the camera dude because the
optics are just horrible here and the
dude is subdued and if you need to jump
on his neck again you can
but to just sit there with your hands in
his pockets and he goes unconscious and
you still don't do anything
right but i never said he will be found
guilty in the court of law
and i think i think the reason why is
because i know policing you know and i
reserve my opinions on
on the court of law because all the
evidence hasn't been presented
and these things keep occurring like
brianna taylor is another one
you know they keep saying that these
people are are
unjustifiably killed by police creating
an environment
of of of hatred towards police which is
a big lie it's
it's all a farce there are some people
who were killed by police
and they in they didn't deserve to be
killed by police you know i think walter
scott was
um castile was the only iffy one
for me what happened with him he got
shot he was reaching he was reaching for
his identification presumably and a and
he had a gun
in his pocket so to the officer it looks
like he's reaching for the gun
it was a legal gun and he was in his
game no no no no no let's talk about
that
it wasn't legal because he was smoking
pot no not
at the time because the toxicology
results that came back in the court of
law
in his trial deemed that he was
intoxicated meaning that he had ingested
marijuana at the time he got his permit
and therefore he illegally obtained a
concealed carry pyramid
and even while he was illegally in
possession of a concealed care permit he
was violating the law at the time of his
debt because he was carrying a gun and
he had
uh illegal drugs in his possession yeah
he's in possession of illegal
illegal drugs while carrying a firearm
so he was all kind of messed up
and but does that mean he need to die no
it doesn't but what it
speaks to is the the questionable
nature of what is the cop seeing and
what is he doing
and he's reaching he said for his id but
the cop sees a gun coming out his pocket
he should have had it in a holster he
should be responsible gun owner and and
it probably wouldn't have been that
iffy this this is where i get more
little libertarian and all the stuff
i don't blame uh an individual cop for
the most part
i understand individuals bear
responsibility for the actions they take
for the orders they follow
but if we're asking cops to effectively
you know
be neutral arbiters of the law not
saying they always are or
typically are but that's the idea it's
like okay we've all voted
legislators came in passed this law now
we got to have people to enforce the law
so we have cops do it
that cop's not playing favorites you
know first of all he doesn't want to get
jammed up and have his time wasted by
someone doing something dumb
and you're going to argue and claim oh i
should be allowed to do this i should be
allowed to do this
look man i know the laws you know the
law is i'm i'm doing what was asked of
me by the community
the problem i see i see though is the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
it doesn't say anything about whether or
not you smoke pot or whatever and i also
think the war on drugs is wrong
i do think there's there's a fair
assessment about you know wielding a gun
under the influence for sure so that's
where
you know things get iffy with with lando
uh
but i'm looking at it like we got cops
uh the the floyd the floyd circumstance
specifically
floyd was freaking out because i think
the cops caught a mid-drug deal
you know maurice lester hall was it was
testified by floyd's girlfriend she was
that he was the
he was their dealer they find the speed
ball they see the blood in his system
i think what happened was it was a 20
counterfeit bill not a big deal
but when the cops showed up floyd was
like we're
you know it's like right now it's going
down this is serious charges so he
freaks out
if it wasn't illegal to do drugs like
that
and you had a right i don't think he
would have freaked out i think
he was driving you can't do that while
you're right that's true
this is this is the point that some that
some people make and
it sounds good in theory but in
application it doesn't work
if you know if you were you see how
crazy he was
you see him in the store you saw him he
was jumping and struggling to stand up
at some point how is he operating a
motor vehicle but then
you you also see that because of his
drug habit he's now using the
counterfeit
money to purchase things yeah so he's in
a sense he's in a sense of desperation
so if the counterfeit money doesn't work
what is he going to do next to get his
high
what is he going to the next to get what
he wants he's going to start stealing
things he's going to start robbing
people
he's going to start breaking he's going
to start breaking other laws that affect
other people
if you were smoking crack in your own
house nobody cares
i've never i've never caught somebody
smoking crack in their own house
because i don't ever randomly break into
his house there he is there he goes
kicked oh he got cracked everywhere
and you know what happens if i just kick
his door in and get out of here
i'm getting fired and then none of that
stuff is pressed in court he'll never go
to jail for the fruit of the poison tree
yeah so
you know exclusionary rule i have
already started down the path of of uh
doing illegal stuff none of that's going
to count
so it doesn't happen so but but what i
do see is that the reason why philando
castile and these laws are in place that
a person is a possession of a firearm
with illegal substances
it's because of the drug game it's
because of drug dealing
it's because people are violent all of
these young people that are getting
killed in the inner city are getting
killed in this ring
of drugs gangs gun violence
all of these things which are trying to
which police are trying to combat
via the legislators and so
it's not a big deal to me because i
don't carry illegal drugs on me while
i'm carrying my firearm i just don't do
it
if i want to smoke we just smoke at the
house and if i want to smoke it illegal
smoking at the house
yeah legal in most places now it's
leaking in most places arizona just
passed a law
that is leaving in arizona i don't know
if it's in effect yet but they passed
the law which i think is
counterproductive but at the end of the
day
i don't care police don't care they
don't care
like about people doing drugs about
people smoking weed oh yeah like it's
not it's not a big deal i i i got these
stories from the south side where it's
like
you know my 16 year old friends would be
like hanging out skating at a park or
whatever and they're smoking pot and
they'd see like a cop pull up and then
i'll freak out like throw it the cops
would laugh and
there was one story where apparently
like my like my friends were to park
they're smoking
they see a cop roll up they freak out
throw the pipe the cops laugh and go yo
we don't care we're looking for a guy
who's like 5
10 he's wearing a brown shirt you see
him like nah he's like later kids and
they just peel they just drive off and
they're like yeah
i mean the freak out that people have is
probably the most dangerous because
floyd may have been able to beat the
case in the court of law
for the if he didn't freak out and be
weird he
it would have just been a counterfeit
thing and the store could choose not to
prosecute
now i don't know if that's the way that
they do it there but in the state of
arizona
the store has to prosecute your crime
against them doesn't matter
well it's a state that that brings
charges not not in not
in so so there's a you know there's a
time period in which crimes can be
prosecuted and not right so
if i go to a convenience store and i
steal candy at a convenience store and
it's just shoplifting
i committed a crime a store can say i
don't want to prosecute
therefore the police department will not
arrest me because the store didn't want
to prosecute however
they can prosecute as long as it's
within a year or so of that crime or
whatever whatever
the limitation statute of limitations is
for that particular crime so
even only thing that changes in the
state of arizona and it's probably
universal across the board is domestic
violence so a woman getting her butt kid
can't say no i don't want to prosecute
my baby daddy today i know the state
picks up those charges
she has no choice yeah other crimes
against persons that are not involved in
domestic violence people can decide not
to prosecute well my understanding of
that is that
what's actually happening is the
prosecutor the the prosecutors say
without a witness we wouldn't win so
it's it's it's always the state
versus you know the people yeah
ultimately it's the state but
we make those determinations at the
police
level so we'll if there's no complaint
right what are you charging the person
with
exactly exactly so but they make that
but technically they make the decision
we still we still report it we still
followed up and the detective can still
follow up with the case
and they can change their mind but at
the at the moment most people they don't
want to prosecute because
george floyd is a crackhead i mean he's
a he's a drug user
meth user yeah he probably smoked crack
too i'm sure no but
he uses drugs and so when a cop showed
up
maybe he would have come in and
reconciled it and the cops could have
assisted him in doing that
but he panicked because he got his dope
dealer who had a bag of drugs probably
and he panicked and swallowed dope and i
know people
personally who sell drugs
who have done things like that and
that's a that's a common occurrence they
swallow dope
because if you swallow it now you don't
have it in your possession
and you can't be charged with it they
call it hooven that's what he said
that's what i've learned in the last few
days
and uh he said it blatantly to the
officer i was well so yeah
but the way pbs reports that is it meant
basketball yeah right i was playing
basketball yeah i mean that's probably
why it's coated
i'm sure he's not playing basketball as
high as he was
oh he's lying yeah oh he's lying but but
in your experiences hooping
typically referred to swallowing drugs i
never heard i've never heard of the term
yeah i mean neither nobody ever used
that term i mean it's probably cultural
you said hooping for basketball hooping
for drugs for drugs either
i've never heard hooping for drugs i've
heard hooping for basketball exactly
i've heard shooting hoops i've never
heard i was hooping
i mean i never heard a person admit that
they swallowed right right they admitted
that they swallowed drugs unless they
wanted medical attention
and they would say hey man like hey i
need the man ambulance i swallow i
swallowed
i think he did want the ambulance he did
but the thing is i think he went about
it in a roundabout way because he was so
high
he was trying to convey to them that i
want medical attention because i don't
want to go to jail
but he didn't want to go ahead and admit
that i swallowed the dope that
homeboy just sold me right here in front
of the store i tried to buy with
counterfeit money
let's pull up the story uh we got the
story from the hill because this is part
of the defense and i think we should
bring it up
chauvin defense attorney claims floyd
said quote i ate too many drugs in a
rest video
this is really weird because you can't
really hear exactly what they're saying
in this video it's just this loud
clamoring
i guess maybe george floyd said it but
to me it's like that
that yanny laurel thing if if someone
plays a weird sound
and tells you here's what they said
you'll hear it you know
there there's this really funny song
where they have it's like it's like
it's a very short meme song remember
what it was it's like 30 seconds
where they're saying the same thing over
and over again the same phrase
but the text shows a different phrase
yes so it sounds like they're saying
different things but it's the same word
over and over and over again
so when they play this video and you
can't really make it out and they're
like doesn't it sound like floyd said i
ate too many drugs you're like
maybe maybe so here's but here's where
it gets crazy
the prosecutor says he didn't say i ate
too many drugs he said i ain't do any
drugs
which one was it well hold on he said
one of the two right that's the argument
so either he said he's admitting to it
or he's lying because we know the talks
report that he did eat the drugs
so what what do you think he said well i
i don't know what he says and it's not
going to matter if shoving didn't write
it in a case report
because shelby can just deny that he
heard anything but the thing is
is that if the the prosecution is
shooting themselves in the foot again
if he said i ate too many drugs and
chauvin did not recognize
that he needed to be he needed um aid to
be rendered to him
then chauvin would would be potentially
culpable
in not rendering aid to a person who
admitted to swallowing drugs
this is and the prosecution turned
around and said no he didn't say that he
said i didn't do no drugs well then that
makes chauvin even more
you know a reasonable person because
he's saying i didn't do no drugs so
there's no reason to put him on his side
in the recovery position that's
that's what i wanted to get to with this
story is that it seems like the defense
is pulling a bug's bunny
on the prosecutors so you guys you know
in looney tunes when
daffy and bugs and this says rabbit
season and duck season and
and daffy say it's rabbit season and
bugs like no it's duck season then all
sudden bugs goes
it's rabbit season and then daffy goes
no it isn't it's duck season
and then bugs goes okay and then elmer
fudd shoots daffy
that's basically what happened they're
like didn't he say he ate drugs no no he
didn't say that he said he didn't eat
drugs
oh okay so chauvin should not have
rendered aid because they didn't do any
drugs
i i'm wondering are they that brilliant
or it's just falling that way slipping
on banana peels and doing backpacks
because what they're trying to argue is
see it's two things being argued here
they're trying to preserve the the
prosecution is trying to preserve the
character of george floyd
so him saying i ate too many drugs is
proving that his character is a drug
user and then he's crazy out of his mind
but they're fighting that they're saying
no he said i didn't do no drugs george
floyd wasn't a bad guy
but that's playing into the lap of the
defense because they're not
caring if he's a good guy or a bad guy
they're trying to decide whether
chauvin was rightfully knowledgeable
about him being overdosing potentially
overdose of a drug should he been
set in a recovery position was he
experiencing excited delirium
which is which is another term that i
haven't at least i haven't heard every
word of the case
but i haven't heard excited delirium
brought up much i wonder if like
the prosecutor or the defense is going
to listen to this and they're going to
get the idea because the trial's ongoing
and then the state process this
prosecutor is going to be like the other
day we we
we mentioned that you know the defense
said george floyd said i ate too many
drugs
yes you know we agree he did say that
chauvin should have rendered aid because
the defense agrees that's what he said
right yeah that's that's crazy how that
works out that way
you're trying to defend the character
they're shooting themselves in the foot
it's too late now
i know you have the audio can you play
that audio is it available
i can't no not on youtube because it's
part of the whole youtube doesn't allow
you to show the floyd incident
i don't know how you guys feel but once
i found out that he had fentanyl nor
fentanyl
and that was overdosing and meth that i
just it looks like a drug
overdose death well i don't know well
just just for just for the sake of
understanding fentanyl for a second
fentanyl is one of the most potent and
dangerous drugs
that i know that exist at this point it
is more
you know dangerous than a horse
tranquilizer it is more potent
in little little bitty grams of it um
if you research and i did a video about
this in the show the phoenix police
officer and i'll tell you how it evolved
a finnish police officer with gloves on
was handling
a drug laced with fentanyl and he passed
out and they had to administer narcan to
him
or he would have died just for handling
inhaling vapor from a drug laced with
fentanyl wow
and our our um department
when i when i was on the department
fentanyl when it first came to re
you know to our understanding how potent
it was every drug we test
you have to wear a full hazmat suit to
test every drugs gloves
you got to wear a mask and you got to
have a complete hazmat suit on because
fentanyl can seep through the skin you
can inhale it and if you ingest it
you might as well call yourself dead so
we pulled up from the dea.gov
an image of a lethal doth dose of
fentanyl
and it's next to a penny have you ever
seen this photo
no i have it it it's it's 1 100th the
size of a penny
a lethal dose of fentanyl it shows a
penny on the screen
and there's tiny little white specks
yeah we've i've heard these stories man
i remember in chicago they called it
super heroine
because like like you said you could
accidentally just inhale a tiny bit
you're dead people didn't get it so it's
like lab created opiate that didn't
exist
12 years ago like they just it's it's a
new thing right i don't know when it is
yeah i think that they're i don't know
if it's new or they're newly
administering this as a as a additive to
these drugs
because think about it see how little
that is you
you get a lot of that it go a long way
you sprinkle a little that
in some methamphetamine which is
probably what floyd was
taking and it'll drive you nuts and you
only need a little bit and you could
charge way more
because you got you got some powerful
stuff you know what kind of meth it was
that was in his system
just mathematically well there's like
methylene dioxide methamphetamine
mdma a crystal meth which is much more
dangerous than mdma
in in the tax report it's just listed
it's just methamphetamine
and i almost think that any
methamphetamine that is street level
is going to be the crystal
methamphetamine because it's the way
they they cook it and
that's my assumption and they begin to
sell it that way and people get in these
little crystals i've never seen
methamphetamine um in any other form
except crystal
um and then if they mix uh
uh fentanyl with with crystal meth is
that the idea that's what the speed ball
is speedball yeah
yeah and normally you know speed ball
can be mixed with methamphetamine and
heroin
um so it's it's kind of like that
mixture of a of an upper and uh
some sort of a down yeah with some some
opiate with the upper you know
and typically it's methamphetamine and
dude that's dangerous man people do
speed balls
that's that's a thing people do speed
balls all the time and
they don't they don't live with all of
that you know what i'm saying you taking
that injustice to your body over time
you're gonna die
heroin is killed you know i had a family
member die from a heroin overdose heroin
is pretty
legitimate you know these opiates are
really really legitimate
and floyd i guarantee you that
methamphetamine
and fentanyl probably isn't his typical
drug
i think that he probably started using
it after a while
i'm pretty sure you use all kinds of
stuff um
they'll do anything to get high you know
if you if you're a crystal meth
you you have done a lot of other stuff
to get a high
and crystal meth is kind of like
especially if you're black
and and and i'm not making in the race
thing it's like it's a cultural thing
in most black areas they do crack
they crack rocks they do crack when you
start getting a meth
you are on another level you have now
branched out of the typical drug arena
that you're in and you're starting to go
and deal with people who are on another
level of drug of drug production
um and that's just my opinion that's not
every city but
in my city that was do you know the
lethal do you know what a lethal
dose of methamphetamine is no i i tried
to look this up it's really hard to find
fentanyl was was uh was easy to look up
not only does the dea have a photo
showing you how just a tiny bit of
fentanyl can kill you
but they also talk about between 10 and
20 nanograms per milliliter is
anesthesia range
where you basically get knocked out and
that at seven nanograms per milliliter
in combination with other drugs is where
you're in overdose territory
right otherwise it's around like 11 or
so now the north fentanyl in the system
is a metabolite of fentanyl meaning he
might have even had 17 nanograms per
milliliter when he first ingested this
he had 19 nanograms per milliliter of
methamphetamine in the system
i don't know what the lethal
concentration for methods i couldn't
find it
but he had a lot he also had tobacco
which is a stimulant caffeine yeah oh
caffeine and thc cottoning or something
yeah that's right yeah
yeah two different kinds of thc in a
system he had a
big combination like i'm saying this is
a drug a habitual drug user
he's going to his next high you know and
this was his next high
and then you know but but i don't think
he was into he wasn't
i don't think he was actively getting
high at the time it's that he got caught
with the whole thing of drugs and he had
to swallow it
and and he killed him i mean what's the
guy the little rapper that was on the
airplane
yeah i remember he flew on a private jet
and he had drugs and he
well prince he died from fentanyl but
that's probably not who you're talking
about no it's a rapper it was recent a
rapper he landed
somewhere he's like 25. and uh they
thought the cops killed him or something
like that but what happened was he got
caught with marijuana
but he has other drugs that he ingested
and so he end up
ingesting them and dying like i said i
know people and i'm not going to
disclose
how i know them um who they are
specifically but i know people that have
gotten caught by the cops that juice
juice
i think it was juice world was it juice
worth something yeah swallowing percocet
chicago airport swallow parker said okay
because he didn't want he didn't want to
get caught so he swallowed
more than you would take you're trying
to swallow the whole thing so you don't
get caught with any of it because once
it's in your body they can't charge you
anymore that's a war on drugs thing for
me though you know what i mean
i mean kind of man it's a whole ring of
behaviors but
if people were just growing
methamphetamine you know which you don't
grow i mean it's a lot of chemical
compounds to get meth but
if you had cocaine and you were just
doing coca leaves and cocaine i don't
even know how it's made but
you're just doing in your backyard who
cares nobody ever know
this dude on a plane but no but how did
he get it
is the question what is he doing with it
is another question
and a lot of times these people are
getting it through nefarious means
meaning that they are contributing to
the cartel in mexico and and all the
trafficking that goes on and gun
gun smuggling and trade and all of that
goes in those drugs getting here and
then when they get here what are they
doing to other people
the distributor is killing people yeah
that's that's to me
if you sell drugs you sell if you sell
heroin to somebody
or you sell methamphetamine to somebody
i i i would like for that to be a form
of attempted murder
if that person dies and you sold it to
him you should be charged with murder
well let's say we we we stop these laws
also the cartels go out of business
they're not gonna go out of business
well you know what's going on the
cartels now
you want to know what they started
selling with marijuana being legalized
in a bunch of different states they
found a new
cash crop that they've started seizing
upon
avocados no joke i saw the article
avocados
yeah so i would even went down to mexico
what are they doing with our avocados
just the avocados that you eat are they
doing something did you eat
businesses because they found they're
extremely valuable
and americans has a high demand for
avocados
so with the legalization of marijuana
here's what ends up happening is they're
like
we used to have essentially a monopoly
on this product
because the government said it was
illegal so you needed someone under
under the radar to come and take it
well if it's legal we're going to
maximize profits guess what
now that people can get cheaper illegal
stuff avocados are worth way more so
they started saying okay then they go to
these avocado farms and they're like
we're going to distribute this for you
from now on
and so what happens is a lot of that
starts a lot of that criminal enterprise
gets
it breaks down because the cartels are
like avocados are legal we just bring
them in you know
yeah the abuse of these drugs i mean
it's a lot of factors man i mean you
think about the prohibition of
alcohol i mean alcohol is legal now
people are not smuggling alcohol but
they're still
drinking it illegally and they're still
killing people probably more than
methamphetamines killing people and
drunk drivers and people beating wives
and killing people
i i most calls that i went on domestic
violence related calls and violent
crimes
people drunk they drunk off their butt
it wasn't weed so bad alcohol
you know alcohol is what i'm saying is
that what i'm saying is that
if you think legalizing it is going to
stop the effects of it is
it's not so making it illegal is that
going to stop the effects of it
it may not but i really do think there
has to be
some consequences because why do i not
smoke marijuana i mean honestly because
it's illegal
i really don't want to smoke it because
it's illegal um why do i not do certain
things because they're illegal
if they weren't illegal maybe i'll take
maybe i'll try myth
or maybe they'll be it'll be in a
different form where you put a little
methamphetamine
or you know now they put in vomit fluid
and marijuana
and it's called uh what did he call it
i forget the name formaldehyde yeah so
they put that they put that in
they put it in marijuana and they call
it
it was a rapper that said it and it
escaped my mind i'll come back to it
didn't hunter biden say he smoked
parmesan cheese or something like that
on the brink you know one thing about
meth mdma
methylenedioxy methamphetamine which is
a type of meth
is used in like couples therapy because
if used right
certain types of meth are incredibly
good for you
but so meth the word meth gets a bad
reputation amphetamine and yeah certain
types of amphetamines if used in the
right
environment can be beneficial crystal
meth though
i've never heard any any lab uses of
that yeah because i think it's
it takes a different form yeah you have
to chemically put this together in it i
think i think
adderall is for different amphetamine
salts or something like that
yeah so but you get into these weird
things man you say okay what if all
drugs were legalized and
and everybody can use any drug they want
so you just say you started using heroin
and your father of three children
you know you you can't be a dad smoking
heroin
all day or whatever how whichever way
you're doing it um you can't be a
productive dad doing these things and
and my thing is that you're not going to
grow it in your backyard you're going to
get it from somebody so if you can stop
the
person from delivering it then you're
going to save a lot more people than
just letting it flow freely good luck
because they're getting it out of
afghanistan
this is interesting because uh i'm i'm
pretty libertarian when it comes to
drugs i'm fairly in favor of some form
of like mass legalization
but with some kind of regulation so the
idea would be you'd have to go to a
specialty clinic to buy it it's legal
and that way they can make sure you
don't overdose it's in a controlled
situation and they can get you off it
they can
slowly lower your dosage and help you
you know get away from withdrawal
symptoms and things like that
i i i've often been a proponent of that
with there's one big caveat that has no
answer
opiates already are illegal they are the
doctors prescribe them left and like
like like sugar like like you know sugar
candies
and then people get addicted and then
they die from it yeah what was that
that's actually george floyd his
girlfriend testified
that they were both had some some
injuries in chronic pain and were
were prescribed opiates and then they
got addicted to it
and that's a physiological dependence so
then they were like when the doctor
wouldn't give him any more they freaked
out and just started becoming
habitual drug users yeah i see that
happening but i think
i think you know you got the people that
become habitual people and you got
people that's just making excuses
you know when i go to the doctor and i
have any kind of thing i i i
elect not to take drugs i just don't
want to take the drugs yeah now if it's
something that you know
your leg is broken half and they got to
give you something antibiotics yeah and
then
yeah yeah ain't about they give you
something that's going to stop the pain
that could be a
you know a pretty harsh drug then you'll
take it you know my wife you know when
when she
after her pregnancy she had a c-section
and it gave her pain
pills but of course we're monitoring it
we're like
okay we're not gonna take that after you
need it
we're not gonna overdo it right we're
gonna balance
enduring the pain and not taking too
much but some people
are you know they people make excuses
man and they they go
well i was addicted nobody told you to
take percocet after
you were after your illnesses were over
just because you had a big bottle of the
percocet
you you need you need to and some people
sell it
we the doctor prescribes crazy amounts
of drugs which i think that needs to be
regulated yeah
i think i think of my wife they gave her
a big old thing of pills i like she's
not gonna need that many pills that long
you know how much money she can get if
she sold them on the street
you know talking about twenty five fifty
dollars a pill i don't know how strong
the pill was but
you you're talking 20 some dollars a
pill and you got 200 pills in this thing
you can make money and people fake
injuries and they get injured and they
get in the dope game this way so
i think that we should regulate the
legalized drugs that we're already
administering to people
we should regulate those things and make
sure they're not abusing those things
and we should enforce these produced
unmanaged like you said you know these
drugs are not being
we don't know how they're making these
drugs yeah you know like i said sherm
you know you
smoking sherm is what i was referring to
smoking sherm
oh yeah with the formaldehyde with the
formaldehyde and marijuana and then
primos
when i was growing up the east coast
primo where you have weed but you put a
little crack somebody put crack in it
that's why when you you get your weed
you got to open it up and
go through it and make sure people are
putting pieces of crack or other drugs
in your marijuana
and so some people smoking primo and
they don't know it then they get a tick
addicted to crack crack or whatever
drugs that they end up lacing
these marijuana with so i got to pull
this story up man because i
i'm sorry i think most of you may have
seen the story but i pulled up snopes
does everybody love snow they're so
accurate so accurate
did hunter biden say he smoked parmesan
cheese yes tell us
addicted to crack cocaine cravings often
drive decision making
true okay
that's it snopes confirm that's the case
scene and the cheese i hear that
in an interview broadcast on april 4th
hunter biden the son of the president
said he mistook parmesan cheese for
crack
in the past and accidentally smoked the
dairy product they say while it was true
hunter biden said i probably smoked more
parmesan cheese than anyone
his statements implied that he mistook
other granular items for the drug during
the depths of his crack addiction
additionally it was false to frame that
quote as a confession
that he sought out and smoked parmesan
cheese specifically to try to get high
i still it's worse it's confirmed it's
worse dude
listen if somebody was like you ever
tried smoking parmesan i don't know
let's see what happens
that's that's not as bad as someone
being like i'm so addicted to crack
i'm gonna smoke white powder i don't
know what it is i don't know what it is
i don't know what it is
wait you know bread crumbs on the ground
just gonna start smoking everything i
see on the ground i'm just
on the ground just picking up stuff to
put in the pipe to smoke white powder
whatever it is i don't know
what it is dude whatever smoked sage one
time you guys ever sprinkle i was like
what
sage right here not happy no no no hold
on hold on one
psychoactive or anything you can sniff
parmesan cheese like you can you can
take it
that's cheese yeah yeah you can taste it
smell it smell like butt it smells like
butter yeah
maybe maybe maybe crack i don't know
somebody was hiding in there but it
smelled like
that yeah yeah that's what it was
somebody was traveling
somebody i wonder why
i wonder why the prosecution i mean the
defense brought up um
like almost if as if floyd ingested or
put something in his you know what they
did they did he they brought it
that was weird but nobody's that fact
haven't come out yet
but i'm wondering did they find rectal
i don't know but the defense asked the
question in the george floyd case he was
like
he said are you familiar with people
smuggling drugs
in their rectum and the defense was like
no and then just moved on right away
because i feel like they were setting up
they were setting some up later they're
going to have an expert come and talk
about something that pooping nobody
knows
i think they're going to go for hooping
because it's hooping when they
they're swallowing
smuggling drugs in your body so when you
go to urban dictionary and you look up
pooping it says
shoving stuff up your butt you know what
i mean yeah people do it all the time i
mean i don't know why this is this would
be strange people do that all the time
when you're running around with dope you
hide it on your person of course but you
don't keep any
you don't walk around with a crack in
your hand and hey hey going to the store
hold on the rubber glove you could put
it you could put it in in a craft
parmesan cheese box
so in the context i don't think he was
talking about smuggling drugs because
he said i didn't do no drugs and then
when the cops like but you got foam on
your mouth
yeah man i was hooping i think he's
basically trying to say playing
basketball he's playing basketball i
mean that's not all
i don't i think he was being like oh
yeah i shove drugs in my mouth i'm out
of my mind i'm losing it
so but he said i didn't take any drugs
right so is he saying he's lying all
over the place i didn't take any drugs i
just shoved him up my butt
nah he was saying i didn't take any
drugs i was hooping that's why i'm tired
that's why i got cotton
exactly yeah he looked like a athletic
guy you know he had a luck tank top on
he probably was he'd probably still
hoop he'd probably still shoot whoever's
in that state my theory is he was just
lying all over the place he tried to
sell a fake twenty dollar bill he
lied to the cops no i told him he was
yeah we know he wasn't hooping
so i know he was like i want to get to
the point of like why i bring up the
store with hundred buying smoking
parmesan cheese
this guy hunter biden can go on tv and
admit to the world the son of the
president is a crack addict
that smoked whatever white powder he
found on the underside of his table
the story about george floyd look it's a
big club
we know we're not in it barack obama
talks about it's like oh yeah i smoked
didn't did obama do coke i don't know if
that's sure he didn't
he said he did something in college
didn't he yeah i thought that's i i
don't know for sure
ta total absorption where they take a
hit of weed and you hold it in
until it completely absorbs in and when
you breathe out there's no that's not
what i mean i mean like
it's hardcore i never heard that's why i
just smoked when i was like
if if you get caught and get arrested
for smoking pot
not so much now because it's
recreational it's legal now you're not
going to be president
but obama can get elected and then come
out because he never got arrested
when the story comes out about joe
hunter biden and the crack pipe and all
the stuff the media buries it
they don't want anyone to know so it's
you've got you've absolutely got an
elite class of ultra privileged
drug addicts they just get away with
they can do whatever they want
yeah because i think some of it they're
smarter you know where was he smoking
parmesan cheese probably in his house he
probably wasn't smoking parmesan cheese
on on a corner of sixth in
may or whatever so the problem is is
that
you know these crackheads are so cracked
out of their mind man they're oh they're
they're out and open doing cracks oh
yeah obama admitted to doing cocaine
yeah so but think about it how many
people have done cocaine and never got
caught because they were doing it in the
in the props of their home they may have
escaped getting caught buying it from
the dealer
but i mean i think that there's a level
of stupidity that comes along with
people who get caught
when as a former police officer we
didn't get we used to have the saying
and it goes
every police department probably says
this you don't catch the smart ones yeah
you don't catch people that's smart yep
you catch the dummies
that are smoking weed driving down the
street banging music with the windows
down
smoking weed to the weed just flying out
of the car and
and they drive by you and you're like
okay are you
really now everybody at the stop light
is looking at me
like are you going to do something about
this and i would have
i would have never done anything about
it i could care less who cares it's a
little ticket that you're going to get
they're going to throw it out in the
court of law you're going to waste my
time
but you're doing you're just rolling
down the street banging music causing
attention to yourself and weed
smoke is billowing out of your window
and in a way you got it because if you
don't other people are gonna emulate the
behavior and then everyone on the
street's gonna be high
driving or not everybody but now you
heard like in a bunch of these states
cops can't pull people over for smoking
weed
yeah i mean even even when you know for
smelling it for smelling the wheat
for smelling wheat not smoking it right
because it's still impairment of dr
driving impaired but smelling marijuana
is not justification for us yeah it's
good
that's been gone for our department
that's been gone
probably since 2012 or earlier
it's when they started it was it was a
case that happened i can't remember the
name of the case but
um once they start legalizing
medical marijuana and stuff the smell of
marijuana is not a justification for you
going to somebody's house because they
could have a medical marijuana card
it's not justification however when you
put somebody on a traffic stop
there's a difference between burning
marijuana and fresh marijuana
so burning marijuana in a car means
nothing you already smoked it i don't
have anything i smoked it
fresh marijuana is a different smell and
that can give you justification to stop
somebody and get a dog or maybe even go
into somebody's is that partly because
of intent to sell
because i think what i learned is that
you have nothing left if you smoked it
oh so you're just looking for the piece
i fed cops pull me over
and then lie claiming they smelled pot i
don't smoke pot i've never
i've one time when i was a teenager with
some friends and i was like this is dumb
i don't care
what was the next step they said they
smell pot and then what did they say
then they
he he walked up to my car and i rolled
out so i got my
my wall of my keys on the dashboard i
got my hands on the steering wheel
windows rolled down
cop walks right up and goes hey how's it
whoa what's that whoa
sir i smell marijuana and i went excuse
me and he's like
i'm gonna have to ask you guys the
vehicle and i was like okay and i get
out i'm in my work uniform so i have
these jumpsuits for for uh
the airline at o'hare and then he
immediately walks me to his car puts me
in cuffs calls for backup backup shows
up
secondary officer comes and holds the
cuffs you know in the middle and then
the cop goes and starts searching my car
without my permission
the other cop starts talking to me and
just small talk nonsense
the cop walks up and he's got what looks
like
some bit of plant and he goes what is
this
and i was like i don't know and he's
like it's marijuana and i was like
is it yours and he was like no i got it
from your car and i was like no you
didn't because i don't smoke
and he was like it was in your car and
i'm like i work at o'hare they do random
drug tests i work with plans i don't
smoke
and then he was like just confess and
this will be a lot easier
and i was like confess to what it's not
mine just confess
and it'll be a lot easier at this point
i'm talking to the other cop
and i guess i guess the one cop goes
back to my car and he's telling me that
it's going to be really hard for me it's
going to get a whole lot worse unless
unless i just admit right now that i was
driving under the influence that i've
been smoking
and i'm just like dude i don't smoke we
do random drug tests
at this point the cop who pulled me over
walks back over
and goes who's the firefighter and i
went my dad then the other then the
other cop uncuffs me and they go go home
kid
and they got in their cars and there and
they left i had uh a firefighter's
emblem in the glove box yeah that my dad
gave me
and once they saw that they backed up
they backed off but they
legit i my car was full of taco bell
garbage wrappers
i don't smoke the the drug like you work
for the airlines you get random drug
tests
you're done you lose your job nobody's
nobody's smoking there yeah and so
that was it the dude pulled me over and
used the smell of marijuana
justification
to get me out of the car and search
everything and like legit i was i was
leaving work i'd work 16 hours
i don't smoke yeah i can see that
happening you know some some cops they
get they get power hungry man
and then they don't want to do the real
work they want to do the easy route and
so
if they can get you to admit to some
stuff that gives a rest or whatever
it's rare i mean because there's so many
people out here committing crimes
maybe if you're in i don't know if
you're in a rural area or whatever but
see royal is probably they're probably a
lot more dicey because they don't have
to work
you do their work in the city you can't
like
so it's too much work so it's like like
please stop
selling drugs stop like i'm just not
gonna arrest anybody anymore it's too
much
it's like if you ever like tried to go
after people you'll be arrested people
all day long i mean all day long people
are doing crime so
but that doesn't excuse what happened to
you you know it's funny because when i
was a kid
i don't blame every cop friend yeah
because you because you know that but
see this is what i want to happen in our
societies that
empower people to be able to do what's
right in that situation when you get
hemmed up by cops that shouldn't be
doing what they're doing
not to defund the police department but
let's let's let's spend resources to
empower people and let's get those
people turned in because
if you what could you have done in that
situation if i was a cop and i was
telling you like look
get their badge number you know and and
you your dad is a firefighter he was a
firefighter
and then report them and your dad will
have a lot more weight on the command
staff because this is what people don't
understand command staff don't give a
f about these patrol officers they care
about publicity they care about
not all you get a little rural area in
the county somewhere they all buddy
buddy
but in many police departments the
command staff will review it and say
you know what screw that guy we'll run
him over this will make our department
look good and we'll do it to him let me
tell you my story from when i was like
15 in south side of chicago
so there's a carnival they come and they
occupy certain blocks because they need
a parking lot and they need space
so the these moving carnivals do a deal
with the residents you know we'll make
sure nobody goes on your property
well i had a friend who lived in one of
those houses we go to the carnival we
play the quarter game we play you know
squirt gun game you know knock over the
clown win some prizes
we go and we sit on his lawn and we're
chilling and a security guard walks over
to us and he goes hey you guys gotta
leave
and my friend goes this is my house i
don't care you gotta leave you can't be
here
and then he's like this is my house
where am i supposed to go
and then we get up and then i start
saying the same thing like my friend
lives here
one of the security guards grabs the
skin of my chest like just like he
pinches into my chest
and starts prodding my head saying are
you stupid
it's time to go and like yelling at me
so i'm like dude just like
left a physical mark on my body and i'm
i'm a little arrogant you know prick so
i immediately call my dad and i'm like
dude
this guy just walked up went on my
friend's property was told it was his
property
and then he physically grabbed me left a
mark and poked my head that's assault
and battery in illinois
my dad goes you're right what do you
want to do and i was like i want to
press charges and he was like i'll be
right there because there's a few blocks
from my house
he shows up he says who's the guy i'm
like it's those two guys there was an
older guy probably in his late 50s
so he's like all right call the police i
call the police and i say i'm on my
friend's property
security guard just assaulted me the
cops show up
and they walk over to us and say what's
going on my dad's like this is my son
you're like you know pull up your shirt
show him your chest and i had like a
mark on my chest because he like you
know
grabbed pinched into my chest and then
he's like and he's probably and all the
other kids who are with me are like yeah
he started
poking him on the head with his hand
like mocking and calling him dumb
and the cops like all right all right
we're going to the bottom of this we see
the cops walk over to the
security guards start talking shake the
hands of the guys
[Laughter]
start laughing and then the guy walks
over and says listen
you know we're just going to say you
know we're done it's no big deal
how about everybody goes home and i'm
like no no that's not how it works
i want this guy you know i want this guy
uh charged and they're like well we're
not gonna do that so my dad goes i want
a supervisor on scene now
white shirt shows up the white shirt
walks over to the immediately
to the guy who who was screwing with me
pats him on the on the shoulder shakes
his hand starts laughing and smiling
walks over to us and says here's what's
going to happen
your son's going to be arrested for
trespassing or you can leave right now
because it turns out the guy who had
committed assault and battery i know it
wasn't the biggest thing in the world
but in illinois
assault and battery is when you you
embarrass someone or touch them turns
out he was a retired cop
so there was nothing that could be done
so my dad who was a firefighter was like
i'm going to file a complaint with
internal affairs and guess what happened
nothing nothing it was just i could see
that happening yep
i mean i i can see it happening man i
mean it's to me
based on my experience is rare but if
you are
to think that cops aren't going to
hold each other's back in some cases
they're not going to lie in some cases
then you must think that cops are gods
you know
there's some there's some fallible human
beings that make huge mistakes
and i want us to eradicate them
and you eradicate them professionally
professionally eradicate the mistakes
yeah yeah eradicate their meaning
getting them out of the fine profession
um not killing them i like that word
eradicate
what do you think about robot police no
no no no no
yeah and the only reason i say that is
because who are who's controlling them
i don't know what if it's a
decentralized algorithm that we're all
aware of nah
you could be like show me your code and
it will be like you'll see like it's
orders and everything but then you got
like who
wrote the code and can it get hacked
it's not just that you got you got a
homeless veteran
with no legs and he's he's he's smoking
a joint under a bridge with no one
around
and the robot drone comes down and goes
violation section two three a
marijuana use in public you are under
arrest and the guys
like a regular cops get back i don't
care about it so bad laws the cop uses
his common sense and is like i'm not
gonna prosecute a bad law right now
well you know i think that it'll work
but it'll get out of control
so you can you know the little drone i
mean it just depends you know somebody
just shoot the thing out the air and now
it's a
bigger deal but you throw a roll of
toilet paper at it yeah yeah you throw
water
but if it was like a terminator but if
it was something that could actually
catch people in crimes and it'll stick
around until the cops can get there or
whatever
yeah i mean that could work but it
that's then you get
more manipulation you're like well how
far will this thing go and what are they
going to do in the next 10 years
are they going to make physical cops
that didn't
use force against you you know and then
they get out of control and then
whoever's controlling them now they make
a law
and they use use of force policy for you
know you can't a machine won't go to
jail
so once they beat the crap out of you
it's not nothing going to happen and
it's pros and cons
so if you jaywalk a cop can be like i
don't care if he's jail walking
or he can be like oh that's jaywalking
you're going to take it robot every
single time will be like warning
jaywalker spotted and it's going to stop
they could make the robot have
discretion
i mean as smart as ai is today they can
make robots have discretion
i don't think they could i i physically
could but not legally i think it would
be too many lawsuits
well it depends i mean honestly it's
walking around with a body camera that's
on 24 hours a day and monitoring all
these behaviors
it could say it could prioritize certain
things because
in any given intersection you can have a
jaywalker and then somebody
speeding any given intersection you have
a jaywalker you have
somebody else doing something else more
egregious or you can have a person who's
jaywalking
and it's not a threat or a person who's
jaywalking across the green you know
you're walking across a green light
um and so there could be prioritized i
mean they can do whatever they want to
do with these computers
but i think it gets out of control i i
the government is not our friend in my
perspective
so you think it's easier to get corrupt
cops under control they're like buddy
buddy and won't turn each other in than
it is to get keep robots under control
yeah 100
100 because most cops don't like these
bad cops
like we had some in my department they
got fired but nobody liked them
it was this one guy and i won't say his
name he's always pushed the limit
push the envelope you're supposed to
identify where you go every time you get
on the radio
you know 2 adam 11 7 that was my call
sign 20117 i'm checking out here with
one at
these cross streets he would not check
out
and just be doing some rogue stuff but
it wasn't against the law
skirting against policy but then he
he does things that lead to other things
that ended up getting himself fired
because
he started cheating on different things
and manipulating numbers
but we everybody hated him he used to
ask me to go on calls with him like i
only want to go on a call with you
because you're going to get us in a
position where i'm going to have to
fight somebody or whatever the case may
be
we hated him thank god he was off the
police department when he got fired
everybody celebrated
there's officers on the police
department that are like that and i'll
tell you one unfortunate thing that you
won't hear people say if they're
unless they want to be completely honest
is that there are cops that
cops don't like and they are bad cops
but they're not breaking the law
right you know there's two cops that i
can think of right now that if you
resist the rest
they're going to work you they're going
they're going to tune you up
and nickel rides huh yeah nick arrives
yeah yeah
they'll they'll tune you up and so is it
legal
yeah if you throw a punch at a police
officer they can fight you back
but they're going to tune you up no
mercy if you pull a gun on somebody or
you you pull out a knife on somebody
i know god will shoot you and kill you
and won't even care about it probably
laugh at it after a while is that
illegal no
i don't think it's right but it's not
gonna get you fired
um and those things do occur so when
people
say that cops do stuff excessive force
and things it's like i can see that
happening
but we can work to get we can we can we
can work to a er you know get rid of
people on the police department like
that we can work for transparency
i i i have my you know likes and
dislikes about body worn cameras
but bodywork cameras overall in totality
circumstances is a good thing
we can do more things like that on the
police department and and make things
better and more transparent that's fine
but defunding the police
acting like every police shooting is a
is a bad
shoot like you're never going to get
anywhere with that well let me ask you
then so
so to the point about robot cops and
another point that needs to be brought
up is bad laws in the constitution
so right now i can talk about the
rigidity of a robot cop but the
constitution says shall not be infringed
cops in new york city don't care cops in
new jersey don't care they don't care
what the constitution says
didn't you swear an oath the
constitution police yeah the
constitution come before any laws
so then how could how could you be you
know uh
in new jersey with this one story a
woman was from philadelphia
legally allowed to own a gun and she was
like mid-40s and she jumped the bridge
you know just like
like drove across the bridge it's a five
minute drive she want to go to the
casino she gets pulled over
cop without question arrests are charged
with a felony for gun possession
she's she has a concealed carry permit
from her state she made a mistake she
was just stupid
felony charge yeah you could charge a
person with that but i don't think
that's going to go far in court
it ended up so for political reasons
this this one particular case ended up
getting stopped but
look man in chicago you got a lot of
people
who are just a dad in a family and he's
like i know what they call this place
shy wreck so i'm buying a gun i don't
care what the law says i have a right to
defend myself
yeah these people get felony charges i
know that's i i i'm like you on and it's
we need to fix these things because the
constitution should trump any gun laws
but it's the cops man it's not the cops
it's the legislators that we elect
that create the laws and cause us to
enforce it because
cops don't make the laws cops don't even
want to enforce these laws but you have
sworn to uphold the constitution
and the laws so how do you do both
so what's constitutionally acceptable
right the constitution we have votes
people vote on legislators and
legislators pass laws
and so when they pass a law just because
just case you just because you don't
like it or maybe you feel that it's
slightly infringing on your
constitutional rights
don't mean that the police shouldn't
enforce them
like for instance voter laws some people
believe it's an infringement on the
constitutional right that they have to
show
identification to vote i don't well that
should enforce that
so the difference i suppose is you've
got i think what are what are they the
the 14th
19th um and the 26th amendments i think
pertain to i could be in the numbers i'm
pertaining to voting
and so voting isn't as clearly defined
in the constitution
about what you're guaranteed there are
some things where you can't be
restricted based on certain
characteristics as the amendments i
mentioned like sex race etc
but when it comes to second amendment
the right to keep and bear arms shall
not be infringed
is it is it infringing on someone's
right to bear arms telling them they
literally can't have a gun in public
well i i think yes but also people vote
for those laws
in the state of arizona we're a
constitutional character my rights
aren't up for a vote no it's what i'm
saying but i'm saying like we put it in
michael malus by the way yeah we'll put
in the totality of circumstances we'll
say in the state of arizona
constitutional carry we don't need
permits we carry everywhere conceal
whatever
and it doesn't matter now one day the
public
in a democracy you know that we claim we
live in people can vote that there can
be
additive laws to restrict gun possession
in certain cases like convicted felons
different things like that we
arbitrarily vote
for laws that thor our constitutional
rights
to a certain degree and we vote for that
and not not
everybody because some people don't
agree with it but some people do just
like
you know that's what the constitution's
for man i know i know and i think that's
why you have case law and you have other
things that are brought to the supreme
court to give guidance on how to
to float with this because i guarantee
you a person who has a concealed carry
permit and they cross state lines
prosecuting them is going to be almost
impossible i can't see a person getting
prosecuted for felony charge if if
they're not
malice if there's no malicious intent no
bro it happens i know it happens but
it's very it's very
it's very rare unless there's
culpability there like somebody
intentionally saying
i'm going to break the law that i know
is present in this state i'm across
state lines break the law get caught
doing something else with this gun
and you give prosecution more there was
a story about an old lady who was in her
60s and she was from i think like
kentucky
and she had a legal permit for a
revolver she went to visit chicago to
see the sites
and she went to some tourism spot where
she informed security like oh before i
go in i want to let you know i have my
my concealed carry with me and they're
like right right this way ma'am
felony charge she went to prison i knew
a guy
is that the full story though i mean
that's full story old lady had no idea
what's going on and they put her in
prison dude illinois is crazy man yeah
i don't know there was a dude there was
a there was a dude in illinois who
uh his family was house-sitting for
their neighbors and the local cops knew
the neighbors were out of town
this kid was eight he was 18 a kid he's
a man now and
he went to the neighbor's house took one
of their beers and started drinking it
the cops drove by and saw through the
window that the kid was drinking beer
and they knew the family's out of town
so they went in and arrested him and
then when it turns out he said
i was my family's house sitting for the
neighbors they wanted us to be checking
on their house
they were like did you enter the house
did you take property
mandatory minimum send them to prison no
these stories happen man i gotta i got
now i
i believe you i trust you a good faith i
have to read
and listen to a court document of
some of some judge sentencing somebody
or even a prosecution's argument beyond
a reasonable doubt that this person
is guilty of this this story was really
controversial
sorry but like i'm gonna look it up man
because that's because there's
there's mandatory mandatory minimum laws
and so the judge's response was
the law is the law i have to sentence
someone who enters the property of
another person and takes property it's
burglary
end of story and apparently like the
prison was was like we
they wouldn't it was like ingestion or
whatever like when they were like we're
not going to fight this paper this is
ridiculous it's insane
we're over yeah inside they're like
we're overcrowded as it is and this kid
who took a beer
and there was like some big controversy
about it yeah i got to watch that man
because i'm like okay a kid and
it could be an in total long time ago
stuff goes wrong in the
court of law more frequently than people
expect but not as much as people want it
to be
um but that's very interesting that they
would be able to
to get a person on that and then have a
complainant i mean you gotta have the
people who own the house have to be
victim
victims of this no the cops witnessed
the crime in progress
and they get the and so the police were
the witnesses who said
we witnessed a crime yeah that's
interesting because police can't
necessarily be independent witnesses of
a crime
you have to have a victim you can't just
say oh a guy stole a beer
how do you know if that person stole the
beer or the store or let them have the
beer
so police have to have their independent
operator they cannot prosecute people
you can be a you could be a witness to a
crime to a certain degree but you have
to have
a victim of a crime to you know yeah
i'll stress this point too yeah these
are really old stories from back when i
was growing up in in chicago and
as we learned with like george floyd you
always learned there was something else
there would tell you about
but i knew this one guy too and again
this guy this is someone i knew
personally he may have lied to me
he was from uh l.a he was driving to uh
he was driving to the east coast and he
had guns
legal guns he drove through illinois
now you got the federal law protecting
your right to drive you know
to move yeah cops didn't care so he
ended up
being forced to live in illinois for
like four years because of the gun
charges
but i'm wondering what so they pulled
him over so basically they pulled him
over at some point yes or something so
my understanding of what happens is
he's driving from la somewhere on the
east coast
and he gets off the highway to go do
something and that's when they were like
ah
if you were moving and just passing
through you had been on the highway
by getting off the highway you're now in
state jurisdiction you're in
illegal possession of firearms yeah i i
i'm not saying this wrong right but
these cases sent them to me man i would
love to review it
i'll i'll tell you it's like maybe i'm
biased because i've dealt with some of
this stuff
yeah so i i was uh i was driving on
lakeshore drive in chicago i'm i'm
exiting at belmont
i'm about 10 miles under the limit
because i'm getting off on an exit
and i get pulled over cop walks up to me
and says you were speeding
phil's out of ticket says sign this and
i was like whoa i wasn't speeding i was
i was 10 under i'm exiting i'm on the
exit and he's like
tell to a judge you can sign this so i
can arrest you so i signed the ticket
okay i guess i forget about it i went to
visit my sister because my
brother-in-law was stationed in iraq and
she was
you know suffering from anxiety just
like you know and so i'm like okay i'll
you know i want to get out of the city
i'll go i'll go to colorado
once i came back two months later i got
pulled over
and the cop walks up he pulls me over he
walks into the window and he goes are
you tim pool and i was like yes and he
goes out of the vehicle you're under
arrest for driving a suspended license
and i was like
what and he was like driving a suspended
license fills it out this is where i got
i bonded he was like
if someone can come and pick up your
vehicle and drive you home i won't take
you to the station but you have a court
date for
you know whether they say it was a class
a misdemeanor up to one year in jail and
a two thousand five hundred dollar fine
for driving on a suspended license
when i went to court and i talked to the
prosecutor and i was just like i'm
really sorry it happened
i was in colorado i was on i was in fort
use i think it's uh not for you uh um
cars fort carson that's right i was at
fort carson visiting my sister my
brother-in-law is in iraq
you know iraq and so but i just gotten
back and i was literally
back from colorado a you know a mile
from my house and he went oh so you
confess
no joke he's like oh you confess to
driving on suspended license and i was
like
uh well i'm just trying to let you know
like i didn't get any notification he's
like ignorance of the laws and excuse
for breaking it
so if you want to plead guilty we can
talk about what your sentence is going
to be
and so then i was like okay i'll plead
guilty and he was like
i'll tell you this we'll give you 100
fine court supervision if you plead
guilty right now and i was like okay
and then when i went up in front of the
judge he said
how do you plead and i said guilty your
honor and he goes and
you know do you state for the record or
whatever that you were in no way coerced
to make this plea and i said
no i was coerced your honor and he went
excuse me and i was like i i was coerced
to plead guilty
so what are you talking about and i was
like he told me that if i didn't plead
guilty i'd go to jail for a year
and then the judge was like come back in
a month and get a lawyer
every lawyer i got said it doesn't
matter if there was a reasonable reason
why
you were driving it doesn't matter if
there's a sympathetic reason it doesn't
matter that you didn't actually break
the law in the first place
my license got suspended because if you
get two tickets under the age of 21 they
suspend your license for three months
i wasn't speeding the cop gave me a bunk
ticket anyway i had no means to fight
that ticket because i was a bro i think
i was like 19 or something
i was no i think i was yeah i was 19. i
had no way to fight it so i was just
like i don't know
and then i forgot about it and then
after a certain amount of time it went
into
uh i forgot what they call it where it's
it becomes a guilty plea if you don't
respond
and i had no idea i had no way to pay
for a 75
ticket and i didn't know that as soon as
you pay for it you pleading guilty
otherwise i would have contested it so
i'm gone for two months right before i
get a chance to go home before i got any
mail new anything was happening they
said you broke the law by driving
then they tried they threatened me with
a year in jail that's kind of stuff i'm
you know so
you you were guilty i mean exactly you
got to say you were guilty
you were at fault you were wrong now
there's great there's now hold on a
second
i was legally guilty but i did nothing
wrong so
but but but i'll say this and i agree i
agree with you but at the same time
this is why i want to empower young
people to
to know how to fight these things when
they feel like they've been done wrong
because if you were not speeding you
have a right to fight that you don't
need you don't need a lawyer i got
illegally pulled over
and i don't i only learned that right
after the fact you don't have to you
don't need a lawyer
all you got to do is go to court and the
state has the burden or
it's not necessarily the same as a
criminal charge but
the preponderance of evidence is going
to be on them they have to show
proponents of evidence to cite you on a
citation like that
so you should go to court and say i was
not speeding um i was on the off ramp
this is what i was doing
the officer pulled me over and and but
it's also things you could ask a police
officer that if he didn't
say he he screws himself like how did he
track your speed
was he doing a radar was he pacing you
or was he
um somehow doing a visual estimate well
so so
in this instance the after i think it
was like three months
there was a deadline to pay the ticket
and my sister paid it for me and that
was a guilty plea
it didn't matter at that point and i
didn't know about the suspension law
they said ignorance was no excuse for
breaking it but i also didn't realize
that by saying okay i'll give you the
money you've asked for
i was effectively going to be committed
to crime by trying to go home
but here's the here's the thing i
realized after the fact when i was back
i was in glen ellen illinois
when i was back it was like late at
night like midnight or two in the
morning
the cop who pulled me over pulled me
over illegally what he did was he ran my
plates
saw my name registered to the car saw
that my name was associated with a
suspended license
and that was his just his grounds for
pulling someone over but that's actually
not a legal stop
because what if someone else was driving
the car he didn't have justification for
stopping the car in the first place
right that could be true
that could be true depending on the
state and also depending on what he can
articulate right
if he yeah if he sees you no but if you
see your driver's license if he see your
driver's license they have a picture of
mbd driver license and the person in the
vehicle look like you
it's very similar to you similar
characteristics he can conduct an
investigative
investigative stop meaning that he has
reason to believe that you are temple
driving he see you he believed that
you're the same person that matched the
driver's license
some states prohibit this but but some
states allow it as an investigative stop
he can pull you over and you've
confessed i am temple okay well my
investigative stop was that i thought it
was you
you agreed that it was you and now
you're driving on a suspended license
i've
found this is true this is the problem
uh so my understanding after the fact
was that
he needed a legitimate reason it's like
i ended up talking to lawyers or
whatever
that you can't just assume somebody is
driving a car because there's a lot of
people who could look like a lot of
people and
true you know i guess chicago lander has
issues with this kind of stuff
but ultimately my my complaint is look i
get it yeah i was i i broke the law
that's a fact
yeah but we can't have the rigidity and
like the system can't be
this rigid where it punishes young
people
for silly things like this and to have
like some
some 40 year old guy look me in the eye
and say i'm gonna put you in jail for
one year unless you do what you're told
and i'm like bro like is there no
consideration for the humanity in any of
these circumstances
yeah i think there is no i think it's
the empowerment of the people right
um it's our fault to a certain degree
that we don't if we don't know the laws
it's our fault that
we don't know because because to be
honest we can all look this up
for cop this is why i think it's
important to empower people to know this
because some people don't know they
can't do this
you can look up these laws and read them
yourself if you go and get put over by a
police officer and you say well what are
my charges and they give you a charge
they write them down
you can go and google in the state law
whatever or municipality
you can google the law and read the
statute and it says very clearly this
statue has to be met
and if they don't you're like okay i
could defend myself in court
your honor according to this statute
subsection so and so did
this and this i was not committing this
he pulled me over illegally
the state has to the preponderance of
evidence to prove he has to prove
more than 51 of the evidence that no he
was right in this instance the problem i
have is
at no point are you informed by anyone
that if you get two moving violations
under the age of 21 they suspend your
license it should they should inform
you when you're when you get your
driver's license they don't you should
you should
because then you have to go through and
look at the laws the driving laws
you should review them and hopefully on
your driver's license you confirm that
you have reviewed and understood the
laws
that are on the books by admitting to or
accepting a driver's license you are
accepting a responsibility that you are
aware
of all the driving laws and you maintain
a concurrent knowledge
or an ongoing knowledge of the laws and
if you don't it's
we need to be empowered because if we're
not in power then we believe that
it's an excuse to not know the laws and
the judge is like
i don't care like why don't you look it
up i don't have to babysit you and let
you know
you should look it up and know the laws
yourself or you can hire a lawyer
or you can you know so it's definitely
difficult
but we need to be empowered and take our
position back of saying
i don't have to default to a lawyer um
if i just read the statute unless it's
complicated i think the system needs
the system itself needs to default more
to a libertarian stance of
all right we understand what happened in
this regard don't do it again most of
the time it's like that
i i i i would get furious
at judges because they they give people
too many passes
um now i'm talking about a traffic
ticket that's that's whack you know
we would go to the court and people
would lose those tickets and they just
pay a fine and it's fine
or sometimes they win they go up i find
that there's not a proponent of evidence
or whatever by the state
you you know you're not guilty or
whatever you not
not responsible not guilty is a criminal
charge but
when i would go to court you're talking
about going to court
they would let people off all the time i
had a guy arrested him four times black
kid i risked him four times in
in a matter of like a week one was a
felony charge of four felony crimes
trafficking stolen property and a whole
bunch of other stuff
we i had a 20-minute conversation with
him coming to jesus conversation with
him
he goes to jail i'm thinking that he's
going to least stay in there for a night
the next day we get a call for service
of a person pulling on doorknobs
he's trying to get in the vacant houses
i recognize him
i say hey man and i'm just going to talk
to him he gets spooked he runs he almost
dies
running in the middle of the street he
goes on a chase i had to chase him down
we ran through somebody's house through
the house
jumped back yards he had all kinds of
felony crimes he could have been charged
with
um and it's another story of why the
lady didn't prosecute and this is the
dumbest thing ever and i have to mention
it but i'll go
past that long story short five
misdemeanor crimes
that he committed that day which is
after he committed felony crimes he goes
to court again
like uh two or three days later i catch
him at a in
somebody's vacant house i didn't know it
was him as a bunch of kids i go and i
recognize him
see him in there run his name he has a
domestic violence warrant after his
arrest because he beat up his aunt and
then knocked her windows out of their
house
so now i've arrested him three times for
felony charges violent charges
he's fleeing the police and he
i think it was two weeks later or a
month later i saw him out out of jail at
a bus stop
it's like how on god's green earth
do you commit that many crimes and you
and some of them are violent domestic
violence and you don't even you don't
even do
a week in jail i mean maybe a month in
jail problem goes both ways man that's
that's it some people are given a free
pass and some people are given the book
you know what i mean yeah and
i think that more people get passes than
the book people just don't
think so give you an example my family
member 70 years in prison
how did he get 70 years in prison he
shot two three people
um and he was in possession of illegal
drugs because i had looked up his
charges and he was a prohibited
possessor he was already convicted felon
so he shouldn't had a gun he shot three
people and he was possession of of a
dangerous substance they gave him 70
years
how many years do you think he did or
he's going to do
20. how many say 20 15
15. they're gonna give him 15 he'd be
out of pro oh i got it yeah 15.
15 years he'd be out on parole which is
a good game is right you know like
we posted without going but 70 versus
15.
think about the people he shot he's
probably like i hope he'd go to i hope
he goes
i don't like the idea that we just say
like lock him away for a long time i
think the idea is like we gotta we gotta
help this person
you know what i mean like i think so too
maybe maybe not if you're you're dealing
with kids
you probably should go to prison for the
rest of your life or you are you have
legitimately raped a woman with force
you should you should go to jail until
she feels comfortable with you being out
of jail that's what i think
different crimes some crimes lock them
up throw away the keys i support
execution i'm just afraid of executing
the wrong people but same with throwing
the wrong people away for a lifetime
right too but you know like you said
some people get the bad end of the stick
some people um you know they they they
had appeals
they were guilty yeah they had
opportunities at fair trial
they lost then it's over look for for
all the problems
a lot of people don't realize we got a
pretty good system well the problem
is the big name a better one every human
every law like the the the flaw in the
system that i'm getting is
every human should read every law and
understand every law
federal and state and local and then
tomorrow
make sure you re-read everything or at
least acknowledge all the changes made
to every law
so you know every law at every moment
and if you don't
that's a problem even the people that
sign the laws
in the into law in congress don't read
the bill sometimes before they sign it
or vote on it see that's a huge flaw in
the system that we're going to need to
address but i don't think you have to
know all the laws just like you don't
have to
know all the real estate laws or
whatever case it be because then you
have you have access to counsel
so people who are experts in it you just
need to know the functional laws like
maybe if you're going to speed just know
the speeding laws you know if you're
going to be operating a motor vehicle
and you know whatever you need to know
how to function the vehicle know the
turns
no make basic laws if you're going to be
murdering people then you need to know
the murder laws but if you're not
murdering nobody you don't need to know
laws around murder
or laws around aggravated assault or
domestic violence or if you're not going
to be doing those things
but you can always read these laws and
be informed
as things pop up i think it's invaluable
for people to watch these cases that go
on
in the court of law i used to watch core
tv all the time even when i was a cop
because you learn a lot like the george
floyd trial people should be watching it
not only to pick a side but to learn how
the court system works so when you mess
around and be in court
hopefully not for murder but when you go
to court you will understand
the value of defense and the value of
functionality
we got to go to super chats okay some
some questions from the audience if you
haven't already
smash that like button comment because
all that stuff really does help it
you're basically telling youtube the
show is great you love it
if you're listening on itunes or spotify
leave us a good review give us five
stars and don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member
because we're gonna have an exclusive
members only segment coming up after the
show but let's read some of these super
chats
we do have a bunch of people who are
basically already saying that they're so
stoked that uh b tatum is is here
finally
thank you yeah we we we get messages all
the time like every night they're like
when's brandon come
says tatum time yeah there you go all
right so let's try and find some uh
that's one of my people
thank you nice is that your show tatum
time
no no no it's just a person that
followed me i see i see the super chats
when they super chat on my channel
sean burrow says today i didn't have to
decide who to watch
thank you tim and b tatum keep doing
what you do
good show so far thank you all right
keith mccracken says
long time second time do you think that
there should be more incentive on trade
schools and student loan forgiveness for
said schooling
i'm an hvac tech in socal i think high
schools should incentivize trade schools
over universities love you all i
absolutely agree 100
i agree a thousand a thousand percent
colleges colleges
it's a money grab college is a farce
yeah you go and spend 40 000
and don't learn nothing and don't do
anything with what you supposedly
learned in the past the internet no i
mean now the internet's out you really
don't your new city's kind of accessible
you don't you can buy books like you
want to know about finances buy
books that from financial people who are
successful you know dave ramsey have
stuff
you like it's like it's like credit
karma and i'm not trying to
you know i'm giving them a bush boost
right here but i don't know much about
credit but i was able to build my credit
score over 800 just using credit card
wow
just i just all i do is look at the
things that they say is wrong it's a
it's free and i say well i'm gonna fix
these things and then you know i google
a few things and listen to a few people
and i'm able to build my credit so
i didn't need to go to school for that
and pay 40 000 to have somebody
right you know tell me about feminist
studies and and black lives matter and
then tell me about finances
yeah i didn't need it all right critical
six games says can you give my vet
buddies twitch a shout out it's
o.z underscore rebel we play warhammer
40k and talk about lore
we're on most nights after eight i'm
maine eldar love the show ian's the best
trevor's the worst
trevor we gotta be nice to traverse
trevor i love you i wanna hear trevor's
story don't listen to the haters
rising underdog says stephen crowder
took a knee to the neck this morning for
the same amount of time he was
uncomfortable but talked and breathed
the entire time
and they put his d on his neck but did
the dude have his hands in his pockets
yeah but the thing the thing is i don't
want people to get you know superfluous
about it but
you know the question is did the knee on
the neck cause george floyd to go into a
cardiac arrest
so if if you know stephen crowder was
high on drugs
and had a knee on his neck would it have
caused him to go to the cardiac arrest
of course a normal functioning person is
not going to cause him to die he does
have a cardiac condition
he does he does have a heart condition
which if i was him i would have never
tried that but
i wouldn't die with george floyd
examples but i love i love steven
crowder
yeah he's rad uh captain says you
finally have a cop on your show can you
please ask brandon about military gear
the defund police keep talking about
because to me it seems defensive only
these people are nutty military
militarization of police is the dumbest
thing i've ever heard in my life
we need that stuff and it's more than
just running around with tanks and stuff
that's dumb
we need ballistic gear we need you know
rifles
uh we need armored vehicles i was on the
swat team that stuff is all necessary
only to defend the public we don't just
ride down your street in a tank
just look at who we're going to slap
across the head it's a lot of it is
handling these domestic terrorist
incidents and
critical incidents where people are mass
shooting that stuff is uh
it's we need that and people don't
realize this too because i've talked
about
you know to a certain degree that the
quote unquote demilitarization but i
would say my opinion changed a little
bit when i had a conversation with
someone on the show about
the um options police have
so if you have a cop and literally
police just have
a nine millimeter or revolver or a
pistol well when they get into a
conflict they have one choice
i can shoot the guy or i cannot shoot
the guy and if they're facing lethal
violence or they're facing any kind of
you know reasonable fear of harm
they can choose lethal if you give cops
rubber bullets if you give them armored
you know personnel carriers if you give
them better armor
they can choose a whole array of things
that prevent lethal force
yeah and confidence too you know if
you're walking around with a vest on you
if like i was you're not over
confident but you you're pretty sure you
can stay in the fight and you don't have
to
you know you don't have to panic as
whatever if you're going into somebody's
house because you got a vest on
if they hit that bullet in it with a
regular handgun and that and that vest
that you got i mean you can fight back
at you to live through it
it gives you a level of confidence and
when you have multiple tools on the belt
you can use other things and shooting
people
when you only have a gun you either get
your butt kicked or kill them
when you have other options you know you
can you can be trained in less lethal
and de-escalation tactics and stuff and
they all work well yeah
all right christopher westaram says i
asked you this when michael malus was on
maybe mr tatum knows something about it
why isn't the state pursuing felony
murder rule against george floyd's
friends
minnesota has the harshest i know it's
that's a that's a that's a reasonable
question you know and i think it's
because
politics that that guy was clearly
implicated in a crime
why why why is the police officer and
the police officers the only ones
implicated in this crime
when through this investigation they
have learned that he was a drug dealer
testimony in the court of law by
witnesses
he was the drug dealer who dealt drugs
that led to the death of george floyd
and especially once he once they found
out he died from an overdose and not the
knee on the neck
the statue of limitations is not over
they can still pursue charges they won't
but they they should they won't do they
should but they don't want the city to
burn down
again so it's political just like they
paid george floyd's family
how do you pay 27 million and we we
don't know who's at fault
how do you pay 27 million and people
don't understand in the middle of the
trial
before the trial officially started
while they were doing jury selection
right
anyway all right stephen moore says hey
officer tatum
have you had many encounters with
sovereign citizens are they much
different from other types of people who
resist arrest
i haven't had many encounters with
sovereign citizens but we hear horror
stories just know
that cops when they do meet sovereign
citizens it's a biased interaction
because
sovereign citizens in the academy are
deemed like the most dangerous
people and they kill police officers at
a higher rate they are
they do not want anything to do with the
government so police officers are
a heightened awareness when you find a
person who has a license plate
that says sovereign or that you know
free
or whatever they write on the license
plates yeah pull the interaction with
police is very tense
because we are told that they're going
to kill us yeah nathan raynor says derek
chovin did not have his hands in his
pockets he is wearing black gloves
oh if that's true thank you for
clarifying that regardless
his hands were either in his pocket or
on his side and they weren't doing
anything
to help george floyd which i'm not
making an argument that he should have
but i'm making the argument that the
optics were bad
have you ever known have you ever done
that or like just put all your full was
it was it
you never quit like unless you're dumb
you never put your full weight on
this a tactic that you use that you use
leverage you never put your full weight
on the leg that's on the person
because as soon as he moved you done you
fall over and
you balance the weight between your body
leverage
and the weight a little bit of weight on
him the thing is is that you don't have
to put much weight on a person because
your knee across the the clavicle or
the upper back of somebody is so much
more leveraged than they have
face down on the ground you don't need a
lot of force you do the thing where
someone's laying down on their back and
you put your finger on their forehead
and tell them try and sit up
and as long as they're trying they can't
have you ever done that to someone
well i've never done anything yeah you
just hold your one finger on that they
can't sit forward
i wouldn't have you do it as a cop
because then somebody they can twist
they can twist up but they can't sit
directly up
all right christopher says tim you've
been challenged professional bmx writer
and youtuber mike feed
made a video wanting to check out the
compound skatepark his tail whip
variations versus your flip trick
variations i'll bet on him
uh that sounds great we'll uh we'll look
into him and maybe we'll have him come
out we'll film a video in the skatepark
because uh i'll be i'll be honest i
certainly don't utilize the park to its
full
extent because i'm you know i'm old guy
but uh get someone who's actually a pro
or has a career in these in these sports
and we'll film some really amazing stuff
so the the venue stuff that we've set up
set up in the external skate park
it's called the grind bar you can
actually grind the bar we made it so
that the bar where you walk up to get
drinks
is grindable i think you could pull it
off it'll be real fun we'll film it
it'll be great skateboards
you do skateboards skateboard yeah i
skateboard i've been rollerblading quite
a bit lately because
it's just like inline skates yeah inline
because
uh most people can't stand on a
skateboard there's like two people in
the house who can actually stand on
skateboards everyone else can can inline
so when i'm trying to get people to go
out and use the parks funny story people
have never heard me say this people
don't even notice about me
um i used to do when i was younger i
used to inline skate
oh friends my brothers go to state gate
park he used to do bikes and i used to
have the inline skates my mom bought me
300
skates wow when they were young and i i
really wanted to be like an x game dude
and then i broke my wrist doing uh i
think i tried to do a
520 i can't remember 540. maybe five i
said 520. yeah
x games got rid of rollerblading a long
time ago too dangerous did they no no no
no no this wasn't popular i used to love
it the rollerblade was way cooler to me
really because i could spin i could do a
720 off a ramp that was
that's this high from the table to this
high yeah i could do a 720. i had an
ability to spin
the thing is i couldn't i couldn't um
drop in from from these big half pipes
one of the things i want to do too is uh
like i've been skateboarding for
23 years wait no no no no no how old am
i 22 years 23
years i've been it's a long time a long
time too old remember and i've done like
so much all the different flip tricks
i've just you know basically done a
little bit of everything never skated a
never actually done full vert though but
i want to get people to come out here
who don't just skate i want to do more
of that i want to get bmx riders i want
to get in line i want to get scooters
i'll give me a pogo stick just you know
because i don't want it to be about i
don't want it to be so rigid and boring
i wanted to be exciting and creative
yeah so if someone's got a pogo stick
and they can do some crazy and a half
pipe let's do it that'll be that'll be
crazy that'd be awesome you know what i
mean one day i got to come in and put
the skates on man i haven't put them on
since i was
young i think i said don't get hurt make
everybody sign a waiver yeah i know
right i'm gonna sue you
but no yeah i think i think it would be
really rad to have someone do bmx
uh so here's the thing i the first thing
i want to do is get bmx bikes because
everybody can ride a bike
like we i i show people we got some
extra skateboards and everyone's like i
can't stand on that thing
let alone drop in or do anything ride a
bike yeah drop being as crazy the
problem is i don't know how to make a
bike
so i like started looking online for
like how to make a good bike and i i
just don't know anything about bmx well
just by the frames
it's just not i went to these web i
could buy a stock bike i guess like
pre-built but those are like pre-builds
are never as good as someone who knows
what they're buying
the thing about inline was like i went
to a rollerblade website and i just like
clicked some things and pressed enter
and then everyone's riding around having
fun and they're getting exercise
it's easy you know we got an rc car like
a heavy duty one that we're taking on
the
yeah we escaped pipe downstairs did get
destroyed yeah we had to throw the
battery away
so we got this really expensive rc
monster truck
and we launched it off a two foot ramp
and i got it it's cool because once it's
in mid air you can
use the it's a four wheel drive by
reversing the direction of the wheels in
midair you can cause it to flip and
change directions
oh okay you can actually manipulate so i
got to go up stop and then do a backflip
landed perfectly however the other 99
times it was bouncing around
smashing and it's a it's a lipo battery
so it got smashed and we're like we
better
we better not do that because they can
explode
so definitely long story short bmx dudes
uh inline skateboarders like we're gonna
we're gonna have a good time and you
know people are gonna do some cool stuff
and we'll film all of it it'll be fun
perfect perfect all right let's see
hunter atkins says tim i used to be
prescribed fentanyl it came on a one by
one inch translucent translucent
translucent patch it is measured in
micrograms yeah
75 micrograms an hour patch lasted three
days evil stuff
that's crazy yeah that's weird i try not
to i try to avoid drugs at all costs
like even when it's medically
like for instance i my ears i had fluid
in my ears and i flew on a plane
and like i still haven't got my hearing
back in two weeks
so but they prescribed me all this
medication he just went in there he said
okay i'll give you a steroid
this this this and i'm like i i'm not
taking none of that i just
even though i paid for i just i'm not
gonna take this stuff i'm really
reticent about non-plant-based stuff in
general but especially opiates and they
are plant a lot of them are plant-based
but like
opiates are hard core man i like to do i
like to do natural
as natural as i can all of oregano i use
all of a regular oh it's so good for you
i try to stay natural as possible man
that other stuff
i don't want to get addicted to anything
nick
says most fentanyl is coming from china
they have unusual laws they just change
the compound by adding magnesium or
something
ian mdma mali and crystal meth are
completely different yeah they are but
they're both methamphetamines
yeah i know nothing about i never
arrested anybody with molly when i was
uh
it seemed like that was more of a maybe
a southern thing or
something molly i think we never even
encountered molly peels rich white kid
party drug
yeah maybe yeah or if you're in the hood
they you know they rap about mollies and
yeah you know and then we say it's
it's a disease it's not people making
decisions to pop molly and all this
stuff anyway yeah
all right toxoplasma gandhi says i have
a rare painful obscure disease and a
severe case
i was put on oxy tens which is in
anything pain meds are regulated
the problem is that they write old folk
off a menu for a disk
and guys like me nada yeah
what he's saying i mean i hope i'm
interpreting right he's saying that they
just write prescriptions like it's going
out of style for
older people i i noticed this and
i'm pretty sure you were identified with
this man they just over prescribed and
then the pharma the big pharma industry
i'm skeptical of them because they give
you something that need another thing
they need another thing they know yeah
and so you got a headache and then
you're taking five people and it starts
with the food
i i rail on the sugar industry non-stop
it's like the tobacco industry of the
50s they're trying to sell it to kids
get them addicted early and then they
try and sleep pills to lower your blood
pressure because the sugar made your
blood pressure
go up yeah yeah adhd and stuff like that
and it's like you know i think that they
over prescribe these things so they can
sell ritalin or whatever that
what's that drug adderall adderall i
know i know grown people that take
adderall but
why is it that people get a quart of
caffeine-laced soda with their fast food
meals
all that sugar gives like your body goes
crazy
and what happens is i could be wrong
about this but my understanding is when
you get too much sugar
your body diverts energy to getting that
excess sugar out of your system
so what you need to do is take a bunch
of caffeine
so that you got the upper and so the
sugar is hurting you
and you're drinking the stimulant to be
active and then you're addicted to
the unaddicted caffeine yeah and you
have headaches when you can't go to
that's why i stay away from caffeine as
much as i can because i don't want to
get addicted you know i know people that
go to starbucks every day because
coffee right here you have to or your
head is still hurting yeah
so i just lay here for two or three days
in a fatigue trying to get it out of my
system
i don't i i do drink coffee every day
but i don't have it that bad if i don't
drink coffee
yeah some people probably don't yeah
it's like if you drink natural coffee or
you
are you yeah we get this like special
organic biodegradable
kerrig thing it's like made of corn or
something berkeley some berkeley coffee
sf bay
sfa i like it very good really good and
that's what you drink yeah also regular
coffee
adam kriegler has his own coffee only
the best
code red says on the parmesan cheese tip
when you're smoking crack and you run
out start thinking that
thinking about all the pieces that you
dropped due to this you start hunting
for whatever's in the carpet
spin the gorilla that's what he said is
that what he said yes
parmesan cheese out of the carpet and
yeah man that's a powerful drug i'm
going to give it
i'll give the gorilla a little spin oh
it's too heavy to be manual spin
but let's just pretend
okay you got your spin beautiful get
your gorilla
crystal sparta says two branded about
opioids yeah but what if you need that
strong opioid because nothing else works
to relieve the pain
it's extremely difficult for my brother
to get what he needs because of these
yahoos that abuse it
no yeah i agree i agree and that's the
problem i mean it's a problem with
everything just like food stamps and
government assistance like
you know i i think that in some places
people need it you know at one point in
my
life i used it for three months and i
got off of it to get do something better
but
same thing with the opioids because
these nut jobs are out here abusing it
and
some of these organizations are just
throwing them like candy yeah now people
that really need it are not getting
access to it because they got to jump
through these hoops so
i agree that that needs to change i
really wish that we can get a hold of it
they used to give soldiers morphine like
in world war
one two particularly in vietnam and
they'd come back from like a
massive wound and these as they rejected
they'd come back addicted to morphine
which is an opiate that would lead them
to heroin and other opiates
we got a big one jonathan galterini says
we should talk about how biden says he
will be signing executive orders on gun
control tomorrow
i only own one gun but i love knowing
that people around me have guns in texas
i feel safer knowing good guys have guns
but what what i got to read into this
what exactly is is executive order
supposed to do because i can't imagine
it'll do much
no i have no idea it'll get struck down
by the courts and finally and states
are not going to abide by they don't
have to you know just like they have uh
you know the sanctuary cities for
illegals you could have sanctuary cities
and sanctuary states for
second amendment yeah yeah okay so
like where i live they maricopa county
and
uh another county i think is pinella
county are
fighting or they are sanctuary counties
to where they're not going to uphold or
enforce any of these unconstitutional
second amendment laws
the atf will though yeah but good luck
yeah they might
that's the great thing about this
decentralized united states man because
in in like chile for instance it's only
federal police
everywhere there are no state police if
you if it's a federal thing you're
that's it the boot is on your neck so
right right there's no way they're gonna
be able to to function with 300 million
guns in households or whatever 100
million rifles
they're not going to be able to get
everybody and and i'll tell you what
this is the hill
that i'll fight on this one um so i hope
that they don't try anything like that
yeah let's see i know jansen says b
tatum do you know donut operator
what's your opinion on him oh i don't
know him man he's funny man i'm trying
to i'm trying to get my videos like he
is man
you know it's funny i thought about
starting another channel inspired by you
tim oh wow you got all kind of channels
everywhere
i want to start another channel uh about
diagnosing these law enforcement
interactions and just giving
from a police perspective because you
don't see that and most police officers
that are currently on the job they can't
do that
donut operator has a channel where he's
doing exactly what i'd like to do
his stuff is funny though man that dude
is funny i was like dang
i'm not funny like because he had this
one video where this dude
kicked he came in the house i think
somebody had a knife or something to do
just
boot stumped this guy and it was the
funniest thing i've ever seen
i i think he kicked him so hard his shoe
came off the cop the cop kicked him so
hard to shoot came off
which is the guy deserved it i think he
was like holding somebody with a knife
or something oh
geez wow all right christopher scamra
says i love that you guys are entering
into media production
i'm a film producer and dp from ohio
looking to contribute i send a message
to spin the ufo and the info email to
hopefully start a conversation
would love to collab definitely um but
there's only so many people here so far
so it's going to be slow growth you know
if we were like a thousand person
company we'd be able to greenlight tons
of projects
right but we're getting there and uh
we're gonna start doing
entertainment shows comedy shows like uh
we're we're looking at a sitcom right
now
really yeah like legit just producing a
sitcom because
comedy's powerful and we need people who
want to make fun of these woke weirdos
and cultists and bring back comedy to
like a sane normal place
it doesn't have to be pushing
conservatism or liberalism it just has
to be regular people making fun of
people who are stupid or crazy you know
right because the ridiculousness is not
political it's just a dummy like some of
these people are just dummies
i don't care what political stance
you're on what you're what people are
saying is just
absolutely ridiculous but i think it's
great we need to win back the war
on you know culture and and comedy
jake the noise says tim cast already the
best podcast out there and then you go
and bring in the officer tatum
please ask b tatum to give us all a
ladies and gentlemen and gentlemen and
ladies let's get into this
thanks for all y'all do all right i'll
do it for him if you don't mind
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen and
ladies let's get into this
i love it see i gotta do my whole spew
to do it right but
i think they got to just though right on
tilt rod says sir robert peele developed
a set of principles that would define
ethical policing in 1829
i believe these pelian principles need
to be re-examined and talked to our
police forces
has your guest ever heard of sir robert
peel of the uh or these principles
no i've never heard of and never heard
of the principles um and and
this is what i would say i think that
most people that that want to criticize
police and it's good criticism i
criticize them all the time
that do a ride along with a police
officer or go and tour the police
facility
know what police officers are being
trained before there's commentary
because a lot of people say a lot of
things about police not not talking
about the person who's super chatting
but
i've seen it come up where people say a
lot of things about the police and they
don't know they don't know anything that
police do they go why they should be
training like this it's like what they
they are
that dude is an idiot he was trained not
to do that right you don't see the
person in the back
we don't train to shoot somebody back
which case was that walter scott walter
scott that's right that was messed up
what was that i went to prison though
right
yeah let me tell you this every cop that
has done something wrong has been
indicted in my personal opinion walter
scott was a clear example he shoot the
guy in the back
the guy had owed like forty thousand
dollars back child support which
his i'm sure his baby mama probably
wanted him to get shot in the back he
you know he didn't pay his child support
he gets pulled over and confronted by
the police he fight the guy he fight the
cop knock the taser out the guy's hand
and take out running
so the cop which is a bad cop and i hope
he go to jail for the rest his life
he shoots the guy in the back no
actually i hope he get the death penalty
he shoots the car he shoots the guy in
the back which he won't but he should
shoots a guy in the back and he goes up
and puts the taser on him and and try to
stage it
wow um i think i think walter scott was
an idiot too
i mean you you got what was coming to
you do you deserve to die no but you got
what was coming to you and that cop
should get the death penalty i'm not i'm
i oppose death penalty
you saw him i think he should get the
death penalty i think any cop like cops
like regular people maybe you can
negotiate but if you have a badge in a
uniform
and you kill somebody in cold blood like
that you have a heightened
responsibility
you you should get the death penalty you
know better you know i'm not saying i
think the leftist would agree with you
i'm not saying a controversial shooting
i'm not seeing a george floyd you know
george floyd's situation where it's a
controversial death
when you shoot a man in his back as he's
running away
not a threat to others you have no
articulable reason and you plan a taser
on him
you have murdered him in cold blood with
a badge on you should get the death
penalty
wow that's my thoughts trevor brandigan
says i am trevor
so we've discovered who who trevor is
trevor has emerged all right
let's see chromebopulus says first super
chat love the show b tatum is the real
middle class
needs to come on the show way more i'm
inclined to agree yeah i agree too
chrome
well you're always welcome man because i
like just a little farther away
when i'm when i'm on this side of the
world dude this is great having you on
the show yeah
i felt like we barely just got into
because talking about the cops and law
is so important yeah yeah and then you
had another guest on here that
didn't know that we didn't even talk
about no knock knocks oh really having
you on with some of the debate would be
cool
that'd be fun too yeah arguments i'm
gonna do it
yeah just a debate we don't have to
argue be mean with each other just just
a conversation to be really good for the
people not like
point to brandon point not like one of
those debates yeah yeah
all right clay pyre says please make
sitcom
um we we got a plan for it and other
things too comedy specials i i actually
want to just get a comedy special be one
of the easiest things we can do
because we know a lot of these great
comics they make amazing
comedy it is you look
comedy is just getting too close to woke
not everyone like dave chappelle joe
rogan ricky gervais
they poke fun ryan long definitely but
so we want i want more of it and i want
to
you know like comedy central is just not
oof you know what i mean we need to make
it sexy again man
make comedy i'll tell you a quick story
that happened to me and people down days
they'll pee to bed and cry themselves to
sleep
one of my really good friends he was a
redneck white guy and i'm an inner city
black guy and we used to
we used to poke fun each other every day
and we always try to one-up each other
he one-upped me like nobody's business
in the briefing
every every officer you know every once
once a briefing they'll bring food so
everybody takes a turn
guess what he brought food for me bring
fried chicken
oh my god he brought watermelons he
brought grape
uh kool-aid something else stereotypical
that he
brought they were like a black person
thing and it was the funniest thing ever
he won all time but people nowadays will
be like
what a racist he doesn't know i can't
even bring myself to say collard greens
because i thought people were going to
call me a racist
they're delicious i grew up on collard
greens yeah they're amazing every every
holiday we had i've never had himself
older but
you know he's basically doing he's like
he's playfully ripping you as his buddy
yeah and it's funny to me because it's
funny to both of us
racism and all this stuff is it's like
whatever he's
bringing up all these stereotypes that
are funny to us because they mean
nothing
right somebody brought up if you brought
a watermelon here like hey brandon
welcome to the show
i'm not gonna be like i can't believe
you know
racism you know i don't get like because
of this
now all of a sudden it's like bad to
have watermelon or fried chicken
yeah they're it's good food what does it
look like listen i don't
i don't know a white person that don't
love fried chicken right i don't know
what's the matter
and if you don't love it you're not
getting the right person cooking it
for my birthday i ask no cake give me a
watermelon put candles in the watermelon
watermelon is a bomb we used to put uh
and i know i know this is
this is real ghetto but we used to put
uh kool-aid packs in the watermelon oh
nice wow
and put it in there and mix it in there
dude that's smart it's bomb
i mean it's not healthy that's why we
got diabetes and stuff but i watch this
video where they cut a hole on top of
watermelon
and then take a beater and put it in and
mix it around and then it
basically makes juice and they tap it
yeah you can put kool-aid in there mix
it up and make it like
juice that's what we used to do and then
you freeze it you freeze some of the
watermelons with the juice on it
dehydrating watermelon strips you know
so so i've never tried this what
i used to do back in the day me and adam
we would take you take
cuts of watermelon and you dehydrate it
overnight in the fridge you put paper
towel on it
then you bake it for like 45 minutes and
it feels like a piece
of fish so it's like a vegan recipe for
making a fillet
that you then flavor so you put like
garlic onion and a little like really
yucky on it
and then we put it on a sandwich with
cheese or something or you know vegan
cheese or whatever i hope my wife is
listening to this because you can also
want her to make that for me vegan
it's it's it's like a vegan meat
replacement thing you're gonna have
amazing
consistency i'm not vegan but i prefer
vegan yeah dishes you mix it in with
with meat dishes every few day or
whatever
you can eat the white part of the
watermelon rind tastes like cucumber
yeah it does and if you eat a little bit
of the red and a little bit of the white
it's like a new food
it's super good totally different than
all of them really i wonder what the
nutritional value is
probably really good i'll tell you let
me tell you something
talking about how everything's racist
and how stupid it is
we we had alex jones on the show and he
kept making this joke about ishmael i am
a gorilla
so we made these t-shirts that say i'm a
griller right
now there was some big snafu where they
got misprinted
and it looked really really awful i'm
not going to get into that i'm going to
get into this critique from the leftists
who are like
it was already bad enough that you made
the racist shirt to begin with and i'm
like yo what's racist about a shirt
where it's a cartoon gorilla telling you
it's a grill like
yeah i don't understand how there's
racing that because they they
think black people are guerrillas dude
we're all descended from the races i'm
the senator from a group
ian a shared ancestor the point is that
her sister
girls and i have a shared anticipation
this was the craziest thing because we
had uh um
who did we have when we were talking
about this was it uh um
i forgot his name apparently no no no no
um do you hear gorillas live in a
constant state of flatulence
because they eat so much vegetables yeah
apparently well anyway
what happens is like when we made this
we thought it was a funny thing like you
know magilla the gorilla
cartoon gorillas it's funny and it was a
joke about you know alex jones
and then these leftists are like i can't
believe temple made a gorilla shirt and
i'm like
what that's crazy dude
listen when it's the projection thing
right they are racist
they think black people are monkeys they
think black people can't use computers
like joe biden
they think black people don't have
identification so they
pitch it out there and they get mad at
other people and hold people accountable
to their own demons
most people don't look at gorillas and
think of black people and then actually
if you cut the if you cut the hair down
on the gorilla they're white
i mean yeah i think a human look at them
if anything you think it's
so humid i mean i don't think of black
people i mean i think of
an animal yeah you know animal
you know i i don't i don't think of
people if i had to think of another
animal other than a gorilla i think of a
human they look kind of humanoid
they do look kind of listen i don't
believe in evolution from humans to
i mean apes to humans or whatever but i
have to admit
that they do look creepily uh creepily
similar to humans we're all primates
they do they look very similar so when i
think about god i'm like
god you really i don't know if you were
playing with us but you really made
monkeys look
very similar to us like they're they're
like one of the only species that look
kind of like us
you ever see like capuchin monkeys
mm-hmm it's like
we're primates man you know all these
different similarities it's funny
watching
it's funny watching like capuchin
monkeys or like other small monkeys
because they just look like little
people you know yeah and i know some
people that look like
monkeys and they're not just cause
they're black but they
actually look like they look
gorilla-like hairy
that was that was racist see when i say
hairy black people in our hair it's a
human race
all right we'll do a couple more um
probably the tank says tatum if you want
to get in touch with donut hit up his
staff on discord we can direct your
messages to him
yeah i'll hear the staff up i love donut
my my my guys keep saying get with donut
get with donut
yeah because yeah we'd love to have them
on as well man yeah you should have one
you should have both of us on one though
absolutely let's do it because donald
was a police officer as well yeah yeah
yeah he does really
you know who he is yeah i love his stuff
i i just i i thought it was funny that
you you're telling that story about how
you're going to get donuts
yeah when the when the guy was like
arrest me and then you have donut
operator it's like cops just ribbing it
themselves in the stereotype of donuts
dude it's like it's like who don't like
donuts though
like do i do i put a uniform and i just
say hey donuts all of a sudden it's like
no i love it
what's the donut thing is it because
there's a little bit of sugar for energy
a little bit of carbs for energy
i think that people normally drink
coffee and doughnuts in the morning and
generally police officers would have
donuts and coffee back in the day and
i mean that's just my theory behind it
um and
that's that's they were open exactly
some of them are open early in the
morning
late at night and uh you know i used to
i used to drive through dunkin donuts in
my patrol car and it was hilarious
because people i saw them taking
pictures of me
and i'm like i don't care i'm gonna get
the cinnamon roll and give me a coffee
before i started saving the world so
yes we'll do we'll do one more super
chat here it's the most important
clarence w says if you don't like fried
chicken you're wrong
that's right you're a racist actually
that's right
it's actually it's actually different
now it's not that if you if you
associate fried chicken with black
people your rice's no no it's that if
you reject
the good ol you know home cooking oh
yeah fried chicken now you're now you're
rejected
how dare you yeah exactly but fried
chicken is good i don't even think
that's i don't know where
maybe maybe black people started
thinking that they do it the best
because it's a southern thing right
barbecue is a southern thing
uh greens collard greens is a southern
thing you know i
i i think that my grandmother cooks it
the best now you know but
i think people in the south they all
kind of stuff you know gumbo and all
this stuff that's the southern thing
recently we made cinnamon toast crunch
shrimp but then we made
cinnamon toast crunch shrimp yeah
because there was this big story
in the new york times about a guy who
got shrimp tails in his box of cinnamon
toast crunch oh really
how it tastes and then somebody used it
as a breading for fried shrimp
and he used he made a habanero pineapple
reduction
sauce and i saw that i was like no no
dude cinnamon toast crunch shrimp calls
for a ginger sauce a ginger garlic sauce
and so we made that it was really good
and then i was like we got to make a
captain crunch chicken
apparently that's a real thing though
people do that you you you the crushed
cheese you take kevin crunch and you
you you you uh you blend it up into
powder you smash it
and then you use it as the breading for
you know fried chicken like a peanut
butter sauce kind of
yeah yeah peanut sauce yeah but then we
made honey nut cheerio chicken
with barbecue sauce and that was the
best
because it's basically just like a honey
barbecue i don't know if you guys are
geniuses or you got too much time in
your hand but maybe a little bit about
not too much time on our hands chemist
did you get it right the first time or
no so that when we did the shrimp we
actually
burned the first batch because the oil
was too hot yeah but the second batch we
put in was perfect
and then when we did the captain crunch
chicken and the honey nut cheerio
chicken
perfect i got to tell you man it was so
good y'all should have
what yeah why you didn't make none
before i got here i know right
yeah what it what we made sloppy joes
man y'all got somebody those are good
yeah from scratch what the heck i
covered them so they should still be
good yeah you should definitely try one
it's it's
it's amazing yeah all right here's what
we're gonna do now we're thinking about
food that's not vegan my friends smash
the like button subscribe the
notification bell and go to timcast.com
sign up because we're gonna have an
exclusive members only segment coming up
just about an hour from now and that
will be on the website so
become a member help support the work
and i'm going to tell you when you
become a member
your membership the fee you pay or
whatever the money that we get we're
going to be using it to make comedy
specials tv shows movies
music videos i wanna i wanna make stuff
i wanna build stuff i wanna inspire
people
i don't it's not about left or right
politics it's about inspiring young
people to be
personally responsible i guess i'll put
it this way
when we make a sitcom it's not because i
want someone to adhere to my political
values
because i want someone to look at those
comedians and say those guys are cool i
want to grow up to be like them
you work hard you succeed you make
something awesome so if we if you become
a member
we're going to make awesome stuff and we
want to inspire younger people to try
and grow up to be hard-working and
successful that's what it's all about
just inspiring the
younger generation to just have a good
time but to understand what it means to
work hard to look up to people that you
know you can be successful and respected
you can do that too that's what we're
gonna be doing so go to timguest.com
become a member don't forget
share the podcast if you really do like
it leave us a good review you can follow
me on social media at tim cast my other
youtube channels are youtube.com
timkasten youtube.comcastnews
brandon you want to shout out anything
you've got going on yeah um
most of this my store the people that
like this shirt christ privilege you
know um
that's that's a great generator for us
to do great things for other people we
donated yesterday
it was yesterday no it's tuesday we
donated 12 grand to
a young man at x for boys i don't know
if you've seen him
yeah he has a he has a mentorship for
young boys did he take him he meant to
him he actually took custody of a few of
them so we donated
like 12 grand to him you know people in
the super chats helped us out but
my store is one of the things that we
use revenue to help out people on and um
it's called the officer tatum store the
officer tatum store go in the store
i think i was gonna make a discount code
for people on your show
did you yeah i did i actually did i
forgot it but i did
25 off anybody on the show they want to
shop at my store 25 percent off put in
discount code tim
tim y'all can't forget that there you go
you're crazy but you put into him you
get 25 percent off so
that's amazing cool thank you you got a
youtube channel too youtube channel the
office of tatum so if you put the oscar
tatum
on anything um you'll find me put the
officer tatum you'll see my store you'll
see me on youtube you see my official
website
um you know uh i have a new site called
tatum report
uh we're working to make the improve
that we want that to be more excellent
so um
you can find me on all of those things
right on very cool
i'm at ian crossland.net and you can
just find all my social media accounts
from there
minds and the like thank you guys for
coming i love you so much i am sour
patch lids on twitter and minds and real
sour patch lids on gab and instagram
great conversation thank you for coming
brandon
awesome thank you guys for having me
definitely man uh and we will see all of
you over at timcast.com in about an hour
thanks for hanging out we'll see you
then bye guys
you